foreign
are we the same person or not and you
also got us I saw this someone posted
this
uh that I follow Sunny Delight Sunny D
is it like KFC they're not actually
delayed anymore
[Music]
maybe it's not real chicken at KFC right
that's true Sunny D vodka Seltzer I have
to I always have to try this we gotta
try ice no it's a Seltzer to Seltzer
it's cold you put in the fridge thank
you oh this is great for getting kids
drinking that's what I like get the
youth hey
to A New Beginning yes I need my vitamin
D
and we're not getting paid for this this
is pure curiosity yeah zero sugar 95 cal
It's All chemical but it's good all
right kids if you need to start drinking
this is the one to do this is like
remember like this is a [__] that you're
like if you don't get orange juice you
drink yeah my Mom hated this [__] I was
like can we get some me too I wanted
Sunny D because I was a dumb I was a
dumb kid I saw the commercial it worked
purple stuff fruit juice Sunny D oh my
God Mom was a little kid of summer camp
like they give you the the like pure
sugar water and I'd be like this is what
we should have in the house and my mom's
like you're a [__] idiot yeah yeah
that's not real there's no nutrition
totally what the hell are you doing it's
a Sunny D commercial I'm queuing it up
let's see
wow what year
look at that bottle
oh it's glowing
[Music]
purple stuff
yeah
I fell for it it worked
wow she had a second one backed up by
the way no kid this age is nice to their
mother yeah it's true you know this is
[__] no there's no 15 year old their
friends who's like oh cool Mom you
should hang out with us all right oh
yeah guess what if the mom was hanging
out this much one of the kids is [__]
her yeah I was trying to be like I'll
give you some D
it ain't Sunny though
I got I got a notice I gotta dig this
it's pretty good it doesn't sound easy
I'm a sucker in the summer for these
like trashy like what I like white cloth
too I like all that [__] high noon is
great that's a great beverage but now I
got my morning drink oh yeah so this
will be good start early yeah
it was all sugar back then the cereals
were sugar the Sunny D with sugar the
Kool-Aid was sugar it was all sugar
Kool-Aid that was the Chrysler app we
combine Kool-Aid with alcohol that
[__] me I was hungover for like nine
hours at like at night that night I was
like oh my head yeah that one [__] us
up yeah three hour rap where bird just
doesn't stop drinking cut to Bert he's
at the cellar just like whoa
Tylenol he's like you're a [__] [__]
If This Were A Movie it would just cut
to us at Bert's funeral
we're just like that guy partied way too
hard yeah I don't want to see the end of
that that film what we're going to
probably yeah true and uh at least we
got to see his movie oh yeah at least he
got that in the can good for you Bert
I'm going to I'm gonna hang out with him
tomorrow we're both doing the mothership
oh [__] yeah we got to get him back on
here when the movie comes out yeah he's
in New York a lot he'll be doing press
so yeah we'll have him back all right
just buckle up because it's gonna be a
long one I know that's one we can't
double up we've been doubling up some of
these days because you know Mark's going
to Australia yeah doing a two-week bus
run
uh uh great but it's like holy [__] it's
a lot it's a lot but man that time off
is gonna be wacky we're gonna be coming
back Rusty and I'll be tan I'll have an
accent
a day mate I'll go now to date for you
Sam
that was my Australian that wasn't very
good look yeah uh yeah I like the jacket
too oh thank you it was a free one from
the Netflix Fest looks good yeah I hate
the artist though that's a little cheesy
you know what sucks about this I was on
a flight once and this lady goes
are you an artist and I was like oh [__]
yeah I'm an artist she goes what are you
what kind of artists singing dancing and
I was like painter shut up you said
painter yeah I was like I'm a painter
leave me alone
I didn't want to talk yeah I said I'll
paint you yeah
that wasn't Titanic they painted her oh
yeah pull up that clip that I send you
satellitude oh someone sent me this one
can we get do you got the audio on yeah
I don't know where to start it but wait
can you make it bigger do you want
actually there you go there we go
just someone sent me it's a guy singing
a song you can't make it bigger than
that no it doesn't listen challenge
there we go I don't know what's going on
here
Twitter it says new Wheels on the on the
back on the Block The Wheels On The
Block
why is there a laugh track people
bigger problems
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm not gay this is gold
this is the Muslim national anthem
who are these guys we gotta get these
guys on here this is the number one show
in Yemen right now
oh [__] sorry oh man we got to get them
in here I mean if I was Simon Cowell
that's a that's we started play it again
all right from the top five so this is
gold
[Music]
this is insane yeah is this your feet
thank God for the subtitles though let's
be honest
you know that sound you're looking for
this is it
Barry Gordy
kid you've got the goods oh wow this is
comedy goal you got to be bringing stuff
in like this more often man
and new Wheels On the Block Peter it's
funny there's another one I could send
you there's like mentally challenged or
physically challenged but yet they're
being dicks they're like at least I'm
not gay you know I'm in a wheelchair but
I ain't gay that's cold and they can get
away with it Mark wishing he was in a
wheelchair right I know I'm like oh
boxing I would push all kinds of
boundaries oh yeah you know curtailing
my act and pulling [__] out man if I was
one of these guys I'd have it made
[Laughter]
no no I couldn't find it it was another
one that was pretty good yeah it was
good it was a guy and girlfriend on a
roller coaster without a seat belt
those roller coaster videos are insane
where the guys like not strapped in and
everyone's else having a great time and
he's like
these are awesome is that it I feel for
the guy the black couple I don't know
all right that's a good prank though
yeah this is it this guy's already
nervous you can tell oh it's a prank
he's not loving it oh
T-Rex
Rex oh man she's having a great time
meanwhile we could put the music
[Laughter]
this looks like me and my
wife except uh I'm the guy enjoying it
and she's like this sucks
oh here we go that was some great
movements this [__] is gold that was
just involuntary straight up fear Pete
coryelli used to have a joke about uh he
goes when I have sex with my wife it's
like she's tanning and I'm getting in
her light she's just like
one of the first jokes I ever wrote was
trying to get ahead with my girlfriend
was like trying to feed a kid medicine
like
big bit of mine that was the early days
I remember all my early stuff yeah yeah
yeah so bad in bed uh me my first
girlfriend decided to lose their
virginity to each other I bled I
remember that one that was a big one
remember my first joke it was like my
English teacher said I think you're like
a young Hemingway and I was like because
I'm a good writer she goes no you're an
alcoholic who's going to kill himself
that's a good joke it holds up it's a
young one yeah yeah
let's see what else did I have that was
like one of the first ones that hit yeah
yeah
I had a whole thing about people I say
oh my license picture I'm so ugly in my
license picture and I'd go no that's
what you look like
that's good that was a big one that's a
good joke I remember those when we were
doing those like comic sets remember oh
yeah 14th and 9th baby well you had that
that big Sage theater show yeah which
for like a Brooklyn Open Mic alt guy
that was like heaven that was a good
show it was packed it was young people
they were drinking that was great I
don't know is it a warehouse I mean a
theater yeah uh that was awesome I saw
videos of that on my app on my uh I what
do you call it iMac that was crazy yeah
I I pull those on the patreon damn oh
should we pull we don't guess who is
should we pull should we play the one of
our trailer yeah can we play that real
quick how long is a trailer it's like
three minutes
oh [__] party's over
yeah you want one I'll try one out try
it they're pretty good purple stuff
oh [__] all right I'm sending this to
you you could just play it right yeah
did uh you guys spend a lot of time like
getting kicked out of class not gay oh
yeah I got kicked out of class all the
time what four oh cutting up talking and
just like a little bit of this
wow that was a great one that was a pro
that's Norman farts in real life
whoa you got that down
Could you teach me that really yeah yeah
I could never do it we're gonna do the
fast ones there whoa whoa and then you
get the other one though
[Applause]
the tricks
impressive
wait what are you pulling up here
nice good memory what do you call me
sometime when you have no class
hahaha
you're all right can you send me that
thing I sent it to you thank you thank
you yeah this is so this is we talked
about in the Greg Warren app where we
said we couldn't sell a special that was
like a Blue Collar Comedy Tour Style
special this is the trailer three
minutes should we play it yeah I mean if
they can stomach three minutes I think
it's pretty cool now what year are we
talking five years ago
2015 16. all right we'll play it
that's a comedy seller great shot who
shot this Jason Katz yeah
[Applause]
we're living in weird times you know
people are mad at men right now we got
to make some changes I'm watching less
office porn personally
because I used to really like office
porn but now when I see it I'm like he
should not have done that
he's like hi to Weinstein there should
be a guy that comes on the end like he
does not work here anymore
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in Queens they're playing Welcome to the
Jungle oh this is a great job at the
airport
that's a weird airport song you think
it's a little much I'm a rock and roll
guy I'm cool I can rock but I'm just
walking through the terminal right here
hey can we cool it down a little bit
also it's a little unnerving to be
boarding a flight in here you're gonna
die
for Mark Norman ladies and gentlemen we
all have sets that night or do we work
this out we've worked it out oh okay
this guy would not shut up would it be
nice as a no Small Talk option on the
end but there isn't so you gotta find
your own way to quiet the guy I like to
scare wonder if this will be a JuJu how
about this traffic huh what do things
causing this I'm like probably the Jews
he's like
oh that's fine she goes wow you're a
real bad guy
I was like that's all it takes
pretty sure the alternative is a felony
so can we can we maybe hold off on that
first we're literally playing audio
[__] Jesus Christ
just puts an ax to the table Jesus
Christ hold on
noises there we go Daniel pass on this
special too
we're trying to talk dirty when you're
married because you have to segue back
into your regular life together you know
what I mean you can't get too dirty
it's hard to be like stepping my balls
and choke me and then be like I'll do
the dishes if you vacuum is that cool
I went to the women's March that was
cool although I gotta say I haven't
heard the word [__] yelled that much
since that time I rollerbladed to high
school
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's like he was a quiet man that's what
they say he was very quiet that should
be part of the background check for guns
like you want this gun you better be
[__] chatty daddy perfect I'm gonna
get very anxious when I fly I'm not
afraid of a crash I'm afraid of a
conversation
I was on a flight the other day the guy
next to me was like what do you do and I
was like I'm minding my own business on
airplanes
my friend's like a big beer guy you know
he's like we gotta go to a brewery like
why can't we just go to a bar he's like
it's fun you can see how it's made I
don't care how it's made
look I like porn I don't need to go to a
broken home
[Applause]
I think it's a pretty cool thing we did
and we couldn't sell this but it was you
know it was
what was the exact premise because
obviously it's three Comics jokes jokes
jokes we're like a lot of comics are
doing like the one-man show type [__]
and our premise was just all of us doing
20 minutes hard fast jokes yes and uh
and that's why we shot it like this and
you know we couldn't sell it but uh it
was fun even to make it honestly yeah
well I mean not saying it was our idea
but then Netflix came out with the 15
minutes and then the half hours and you
know this was this was a good idea
yeah I think they wanted I think we were
probably two similar on One show but I
thought that's what was kind of cool
about it I thought we were all just guys
who were like kind of Throwbacks yes and
the other alternative title was three of
a kind you know because like Hey we're
similar we have jokes back to back but
yeah but uh
yeah you know fun thing to do but uh
it's funny if you've got Berkowitz on
this now this would this would sell for
a couple mil and we'd say [__] you we're
going to do the road I mean we'll do our
own hours it was
it was
very discouraging I remember yeah trying
to sell this and getting like a Maybe
from quibby it like it's like literally
like a joke like a company that folded
and like too much was like We'll see
yeah and their idea was like we'll make
it a series so then another group of
three friends will have us a show then
another group and we think the boss is
right there in front of you these three
guys and we felt weird about doing that
we I think Mark and Joe and I were all
kind of like and we feel weird about
because then they're going to get
involved in the like if we get all the
comics we were down but then also like
do we even want to be Bookers exactly
Peters do it for the podcast we don't
want to book people on the podcast yeah
and they were like how about this guy or
how about this lady we're like oh they
suck yeah yeah but she's in a wheelchair
like I don't care and they didn't like
that yeah his punchline is I'm not gay
I'm like you gotta listen to it man it's
[__] crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry about that we were uh we were in a
moment right there yeah we're in a time
you were basically the guy who walked
into the movie theater late and he's
like hey where are we sit
there's Sharon Stone's uh Crossing her
legs here
so yeah
yeah that was a good scene oh
oh yeah that movie a lot as a kid oh
yeah oh yeah the ice pick all that [__]
yeah but if you jerk off the murder yeah
yeah well a naked woman killing a guy it
was the same with Gone Girl there's
something hot about a woman being that
[__] bad [__] yeah yeah I don't know
what it is
what was the first uh moment you knew
you were straight you're like oh I know
mine what is it uh Dirty Dancing wow
feel free to pull this up the underwear
scene where Jennifer Gray and the other
blonde lady are dancing together and
like kneeling and walking crawling
towards each other I got my first boner
that I ever remember that was at my old
house in New Orleans parents were there
I didn't know what was happening I
thought something was broken very
exciting
must have been like 89 or so I got a
confession to make I've never seen Dirty
Dancing well I mean it's not great I
just it's one of those movies you always
miss a couple yeah and like that's one
that I know is a classic it's just a
sexy rom-commy kind of
yeah it's when the girls I saw a
Roadhouse late too I was late in a
couple I saw that late great great fun
but like uh and Sam Elliott and [__]
this is it he's watching them and the
music's great they're all hot they're
all sexy and sweaty and they're in a
warehouse after hours learning a dance
this is my first boner
Montage that it was like at the
beginning it's guy girl
then it's uh I mean look at this anyway
and then it's
a guy watching two girls yes yes which
is structured Like a Porn oh you might
have some here that's blonde it's so hot
and Jennifer Gray was so pretty remember
Tom McCaffrey's joke about the guy who's
jerking off in the corner of the porn
like I thought that was weird and I
realized oh that guy's there so I have a
character that I can relate to
such a simple premise so funny man he's
great he's great comedy this was it the
underwear I mean come on I was you know
uh the Wii toddler and this this is
pre-internet porn so this was really
something I'm thinking what year did
wild things come out that was a big one
for me 96. I'm gonna say no I mean well
then yeah I mean that was uh
I mean Denise Richards Nev Campbell is
pretty hot for sure well you're gonna
you're gonna go off of that I was
enjoying that
man that was bringing me back
that also it was a simpler time when you
didn't have just MILF access at your
fingertips so you really had to cherish
these bikinis and everything yeah uh
who's this looks like a guest bring them
in
hey
[Applause]
is the next guest gonna sit here yeah
there or there whatever you want
whatever I don't care we're talking our
first boners yeah Wild Things Wild
Things was up there for me I think just
like young Denise Richards Starship
Troopers too oh forget about it I mean I
mean any of those 90s like you know sexy
what what were your like early movies
guys like porkies Porky's was big
Revenge of the Nerds Revenge of the
Nerds although a lot of those scenes are
rape if you look back I mean they could
double as like an SVU episode now but in
the time I was like [__] we've got
Bush let's go yeah yeah he did didn't he
give her oral without her consent and
then yes she decided afterwards she
liked it yes okay you know he was
sweating he was like thank God yeah
which I guess in Sweden now doubt you
know it's like what they change the law
oh really whoa really rape convictions
went up 75 percent in Sweden whoa like
contractual paperwork now no it's got
they've widened the definition of rape
include being in the room damn what yeah
oh wow honeymoon yeah
full consent has to be consensual it's
not enough that it was forced it has to
be like there's gotta be like a video
documenting that she is wow that's not
making that up that's tough times over
in Sweden damn or good times if you're a
lady I get but I think a lot of ladies
like a little bit of uh you know mystery
you better keep that talk out of Sweden
mystery is a great way to put it how was
your sexual massage mysterious
I was like an Alfred Hitchcock novel but
I don't think a lot of ladies are like
Hey we're in the mood sign this that's
right you know I'm just saying my wife
would hate that yeah she likes a real
Slam against the wall you know drugs
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know she was a hermaphrodite that's
not true that's rumors that's not true
that's Richard Gere had a gerbil in his
butt yeah Phil Collins invited that guy
to the concert as revenge and Jamie Lee
Curtis has a penis none true right I
don't think any of them are true don't
forget Rod Stewart drank a gallon of [__]
or whatever that one that was another
one yeah well here we go a gallon of [__]
yeah how does that even happen I don't
know but this was a movie seller yeah
half his body weight but back in the day
when a woman had tits out in a movie
that was like oh we gotta go see that
movie yeah like that was enough yeah
she's a she had a great rack there yeah
could you imagine trying to yank to that
now no forget about it my dick would be
like don't even wake me up for this what
do you do you look down there'd be no
skin left yeah right what is Phil
hanley's line about that like this girl
she gave me a still photo she's like I
want you to drink off to this and he's
like what are my World War II Gi Oh
that's funny that's a good point yeah
they could just read a letter
yeah my dearest Hannah
yeah so good I used to lay the magazines
out like uh like Calvin Klein ads uh and
then do like moving pictures it's like a
compilation yeah I do a compilation it's
the Amish version
that was back when you needed a VHS yeah
and they weren't easy to get no no it
wasn't easy to get and they were weird
and blue or orange for mine was orange
my parking before when before everything
was accessible on the internet you would
have to like go to a weird Bodega and a
guy with a lazy eye I'm telling my story
would sell it to me and uh he he would
just give us free porn he would he if we
bought one he just he like thought it
was funny that we were so young we were
like kids so he would just give us I
remember he gave me one that was just
like fat chicks I was a kid I was
curious I was like I want to see and
then he gave me uh oh and it was called
older Rod Riders it was the other one
yeah older women I remember my dad found
that DVD and he was like what the [__]
and I was like that was a talk
older Rod Riders yeah that one good no
yeah that's what guys used to pay porn
forward you know you'd use it yes pass
it on yes yeah it's like doing good
deeds you'd use it done with it pass it
on the cool older brother and every Rock
and every like teen sex comedy was like
I bestowed to you my you know yeah my
DVD collection and you would like the
VHS you would rewind it so much or fast
forward yes it would rip and then you'd
tape it back together wear and tear and
there'd be a little Slither part yeah
and you'd fast forward past it and you
just have to uh you'd have to enjoy it
with the fuzz in it totally I lived in a
building in college with like a bunch of
dudes in this building and we all had a
different unit and when one guy left we
all made friends one guy left and in my
mailbox was just a wad of we remember we
o-u-i pull this up it was a magazine it
was a porn magazine and we is yes in
French oh so this is New Orleans stuff
yeah yeah yeah so this was scummy slimy
I mean this is on Penthouse this is way
better than another French magazine no
means no
isn't this just like a regular like
Vanity Fair for French people yeah I
guess so I guess so but he he left me a
lot of these and it was the best day of
my life as a college kid dude some of
that [__] you you would do it too early
as a kid I remember like the first time
I saw a Cherry Magazine I'm not ready oh
cherries back I need to stick with like
Hustler or Playboy I I wasn't ready for
it uh Cherry was uh young girls what was
that what it was that's what they call
it Cherry because you like pop in the
chair oh I didn't even know well I
remember like Club was a little more
hardcore yeah yeah there was a couple of
them yeah I think Charlie was like teens
it's kind of weird that teens is still a
googleable category right it isn't team
18 is legal but only for two there's
then there's like seven other teens
that's true there's more teens that are
not legal than there are it should be
called late teens it should be called
late teens you're right or it should
just be called 18 and up
yeah why we why are we tempting
yeah it seems all right you're killing
me with this porn here you're
distracting me I can't yeah you look
like the dude that goes to the porn
store that doesn't have right now
yeah you look like you're wearing a
disguise right now you look like you're
in uh an old jerk theater
yes you look like I'm missing is the
fake mustache you look like the cops
have removed the raincoat
it's just a giant erection we're like oh
my God
have you heard Ronan hershberg's bit
about how we owe Pee-wee Herman an
apology for doing what he was exactly
supposed to be doing in a porn movie
theater
Fred Willard too he did it he got bust
in a porn theater yeah I guess the thing
was he was PeeWee Herman so it's like he
was a kid
star we should know that by now like
whatever the you think the person is or
whatever they're famous for they are
probably the opposite of that Ellen yeah
Ellen Cosby it's just priests yeah it's
so true yeah this should be a word for
that yeah yeah right well like a lot of
clean comics are [__] psychos oh yeah
yeah ones who don't curse those are the
ones you got to watch oh yeah oh yeah
Chris yeah yeah Keith Albertson look
under his back
there's a dead prostitute somewhere in
the midwest you hear that Andrew
Hendrickson
no one knows who these people are the
nicest guys too yeah funny guys nice
guys this was the Muff days when it was
just full when you were you it was full
Bush yeah so yeah
it's just like yeah never good it gets
messy the wetness the gym is in the hair
it's not a great moment yeah it was
definitely harder on oral yes you're
doing this [__] you know you're sifting
yeah I mean muff made me think I was gay
for a couple years because I admit I
wasn't into oral because every time I
went down there a lot of the fumes get
caught in the hair oh so I was like well
I guess if I don't love oral that means
I probably should check in on penises or
whatever right right plus you got the
Muff right on the nose it was right
there you get hair in your mouth even in
the 90s yeah I mean there's no girls
when we were young shaved it was like
Kobe in the 90s when he had a little
mini fro oh yeah and then it was like
2008 he shaved it I was like thank God
and they both hit a chopper all right
Jesus Christ
um but yeah he did have a little cute
fro would you put pull the darkest what
is that uh blackface what are you doing
here is that Al Jolson what are you
drinking by the way beer gee what's
what's on the uh we're just doing like a
little Margarita action but if you want
to get experimental I was thinking of
doing like a little cross between like a
traditional margarita and a paper plane
I would love a weird little uh journey
I just thought he was there supposed to
be mixing drinks the whole podcast like
this
how long does it take to make three
the worst audio podcast idea ever just a
guy it's authentic I mean amdr is ADM
SMR what is that it's where you get
turned on my noises I love ASMR what is
that so it's like girls like whispering
to you really yeah it's great if you
have like a cold mom yeah yeah you
didn't get enough hugs girls who whisper
to you and you just they help you fall
asleep and feel nice what you gotta try
this and they'd make like sounds on the
mic they go they make like crackle
noises and it's just like a lot of them
are hot and they make a lot of people
tune in some of them got millions of
views what what damn because I do the
Babbling Brook and the the rain I've
done all that [__] but I never did a
lady oh check out ASMR I do a noise
machine you gotta have something going
these days yeah you can't just be sober
no I put a podcast in one in one ear
yeah yeah there's ASMR it gives you like
Tangles it feels like someone's
interesting yeah
that's how burnt out we are we need to
go back to the just the senses you know
I think this girl was on Cherry Magazine
yeah it's getting uh we're in content
overload a little bit yeah yeah we are
it's all all our rods and cones are
fried I was just walking through
Manhattan and it has a it has a
cleveland-like feel I think
and I was thinking probably like 70 of
office space is Now podcast Studios
probably oh 100 like this was probably a
law firm at one point
definitely Norman de Morrell yeah what
can we do for you it starts out as uh
like sweatshoppy you know cheers fella
great to see you Jana it's been too long
it's been a while a lot of Escape rooms
too you know it's and vape shops those
took over a lot of spaces but it started
out as like Sweatshop Warehouse [__]
like Soho Tribeca that was all like me
this is great packing sweatshops fabric
making uh SO sewing machines going 100
and then now that and it was apartments
and now you're right it's going into
podcasts that's the worst thing you
could say about a city is though it's
got a cleveland-like feel yeah
I love Cleveland but it means things are
going a little down even the most loyal
Cleveland fans did not take that pot
I I mean I will say too Cleveland
hilarity is still like my favorite one
of my favorite clubs in the country it's
great to get a bat that you can't bring
on the plane
so random that Nikki now he gives you a
bat after you're done and hilarities put
your name and engraved you're named in
it and you're just like what's the
connection between a club and uh there
is none it's random he's got like a
friendship with a guy who makes like
wood and stuff you just came on one
night and my wife just had a fishing rod
for me just right all right yeah yeah
everything oh another guess here we need
another fourth drink there we go brother
how are you what's up man thanks for
doing it we're just hanging out get this
man a drink will ya can you drink yeah
all right I didn't know if you were
driving we also have Sunny Delight vodka
if you want to try pressure sweet
traffic not bad seduce children
yeah that is yeah they're definitely not
being subtle about who they're marketing
I know right yeah poor kids that's
horrible Are you a spanic drink
[Music]
the Dominican Kid Next Door did you grow
up on yellow water with sugar
[Applause]
someone choke out a homeless guy yeah
all right I almost saw a shootout on the
a train on the way here yeah guy had a
knife really two cops holding the guns
you know just like oh don't don't do it
man don't do it and the guy is like it's
just a knife just a knife that I got on
the train yeah New York was he black the
guy with the was the guy black black two
white cops black guy and the worst part
was there was some lady with her their
head shaved and she was filming it like
she was a hero she's like in case
something goes down I'll get the footage
you're like get out of here yeah let the
cops do their thing what are you doing
this guy's got a knife oh dude that's so
bad that like now that do something
means like grab your phone completely
yeah they don't even do it anything they
just look at it they just watch somebody
get beaten yeah that's [__] up man you
think about how rare it is to have an
unfilmed moment and like it's wild even
when someone kills someone or something
like now you can watch the security
footage of like the whole murder like
yeah like the documentary is just like
him going into the apartment him coming
out him going to the store to buy the
cleaning products it's like everything
is filled was that George Floyd thing
was like awkwardly long how they just
watched it for that long I know it's
like fast forward and it was just still
yeah
okay
look at the DVDs like skip scene
one of the commentary
sorry but yeah no it was so long it was
crazy it was long no it just it was yeah
you think like the Irishman it needed so
the violence was way more realistic yeah
I wonder if the guy who filmed his
approoter footage they were like come on
[__] always filming enjoy the moments
were weird yeah now it's like it's like
we've not filmed anything four guys were
on a podcast right now no we film
everything yeah yeah dude thank you man
thank you so much dude Cheers Cheers
Cheers everybody Cheers
Cheers yeah
thank you beard you cheers what kind of
tequila we doing uh Casa Migos
oh that's good stuff really nice it has
like a little bitterness to it too so
yeah if somebody's a little sweet takes
it out I love it really well done yeah
very nice real nice let me just say this
oh yeah
oh did you just [__] yourself
dude that's a [__] your pants that's
what you call an uncooperative fart life
is like LeBron he's slowing down I mean
yeah it was like years of farting
perfectly and then you know he hits a
certain age oh dude I felt your pain
with that that was rough that was like
the George Floyd video for so long but
it did happen and we just kept watching
over it's like yeah it was one of those
except now we can't breathe
I will play well on the internet four
white guys talking about that
that's what thrives on the internet
have you seen Tim Dillon
he's doing very well this is what you
call right wing Hollywood
well Tucker's out yeah
no Rider strike here yeah
it's uh Austin's like a republican L.A
now yeah
San Antonio is great you know great
great Mexican food great that's about it
yeah yeah Spurs you got a basketball
team yeah they got a ticket and there's
people walking upright yeah
you got the Riverwalk that fake kind of
canal yeah that dirty stream you could
jump over they call it a river
if you take a gondola ride and see a
Best Western
that is a needle needle floating next
people fought and died here now fat
people wear fanny packs you know it's
awkward when the Mexican goes to the
Alamo he's like this is cool
it's weird when you go to those cities
that have all those just scooters just
flung about the bird scooters I'm always
like is anyone worried about all these
missing kids yeah yeah was there a
killer clown around here why are they
[__] we'll find them we just gotta
jangle these yeah
[Laughter]
you like Texas or you don't like it I do
I uh Houston's like a little boring it's
you know it's fine you know it's so
sprawling so it's so that's my problem
with Texas overall was like and San
Antonio cool City but you want to go
anywhere it's 25 minutes everywhere the
same problem with L.A that's true yes
like you go to La and you're like people
like come come hang out you're like cool
oh on uh on my ways it says that you're
an hour and a half away yeah yeah 10
miles you know but yeah there's no
Subway or anything you could never leave
New York right yeah you you but you
you're outside the city but you're still
here still here yeah I believe you I'm
buying a place in Brooklyn I'm I'm here
to stay I just like it here I I go
somewhere else it's fun to visit it's
fun to leave New York but you got to
come back right it's the best yeah yeah
because if the treadmill is not on I
won't run yeah New York the treadmill is
definitely on it's like a narcissistic
woman who you're in a relationship with
who [__] really good yeah
the city has an inflated sense of self
yes it tells you how great it is all the
time and you're like you're not that
great and she's like why don't you leave
and you're like oh you're pretty great
yeah they're pretty great yeah [__]
stinks I mean it smells horrible always
sometimes yeah yeah but that's good it's
good but the bags are piling up
I saw a rat run out of it once
it feels very incredible this is like
dangerous good he's a pro this is like
these would go down too good yeah oh
yeah
all right keep them coming do they got
you a stool back there you just had
attention the whole time
I was hammered on a plane last night oh
yeah yeah from La me and my wife went to
a wedding up in Wine Country oh yeah we
were just yeah we were just hammered on
the plane because we got to the Delta
Sky Lounge it's like two hours early two
hours early and they just started making
cocktail oh dude like free like they've
just given me yeah purple Margaritas
dude Stacy got hammered she passed out
and then I just stayed up and I was
eating meatballs and [__] I could never
get on a plane drunk why not really yeah
it's a great time occasionally I have a
panic attack on a plane wow
I get on a plane I prepare for war I
prepare for anxiety War I'm Like
Anything Could Happen don't even Buzz
would chill you out yeah no the booze
dehydrate you and then I worry I'm
dehydrated then the low oxygen No
actually that's what weed would do to me
but there we go
[Music]
yeah you should [__] call a synagogue
and report that
dude like it's possible to go past 35
I woke up the middle of night just
shaking like it was awful it was
terrible sweating and all that [__] yeah
middle of the night yeah like you woke
up to him yeah yeah whoa I had my first
one in the third grade and I didn't know
I thought I was dying I was just sitting
there just looking around freaking out
in third grade like that's unbelievable
35 third grade yeah
what's the problem no it's just brutal
divorce
yeah yeah so what was your your bad
dream or something bad dream and then I
don't know I just started I was like I'm
dying I thought it was dying it was like
an hour of me thinking I'm dying heart
racing a woman I was with like talking
me off a ledge and uh and I was like I'm
okay I'm okay but it took me like an
hour to think I was okay and then the
next day I was shaking up and then yeah
that's a nice hooker
so then she uh convinces us to go and
I'm not tour with like my whole crew
it's you know veter Gary veter uh James
Webb who films and then uh we have a
tour manager Brian and she's like we
should go to a yoga class we go to a
Bikram Yoga class which by the way
started going to like hot yoga I love it
Bikram sucks I don't like Bikram it's an
hour and a half it's the hottest when
we're in Baltimore it's the hottest room
I've ever been in and my tour manager
Brian who like who like try to get deals
everywhere which is like great I love
him for doing it we have a restaurant
he's like I'm touring with an artist
he's a comedian whatever he'll do stuff
she does that when he does a yoga
reservation we go in there so she goes
like here we have a comedian
oh no he's like do you want to tell a
joke and he could tell I'm like no so so
he he falls in the sword for us and he
goes I'll tell a joke good he does one
of my bits this is the bit he does he
goes so my friend goes my girlfriend
just had a miscarriage in the shower and
I go wow worst baby shower ever
that's the joke he tells in a in a yoga
class full of women
and the teacher goes well I'm triggered
no laughs no laugh so you just get it
there's one Jack black dude who laughed
his ass off
she goes well I'm triggered but then she
goes but you know what being triggered
sometimes is good yeah oh okay I think
it's important to be triggered and she
and then I was like geez of all the
[__] jokes like that's the one that
came to me that's Ryan God bless you
yeah
it's an old age she's a good one it's an
oldie yeah just just not appropriate in
a yoga class yeah
he could have picked so many others
being on the road with you you look kind
of like the Jackie Robinson of rape
jokes oh thank you oh yeah yeah like you
were an early cancel yeah I think of
myself sure
yeah because I said no too and uh when
was the internet
it was 2013 when they when they came out
yeah oh because Colin Quinn talked about
that I remember we were at JFL and he
did that address and he talked about
that I know yeah you didn't like that he
did that no no he was like when I was
getting it was like the first big thing
that happened to me and you were kind of
like I was thinking it would be Conan
but uh but here I am getting blasted on
the internet and uh for for jokes I was
like you know they were structured jokes
I wasn't trying to actually offend
anybody you're such a joke it's just a
jokey joke like I remember when you
opened for Jim Jefferies I was standing
next to him you did that joke and he
goes That's a good joke yeah and and I
love Jim by the way you know but I
remember yeah I wrote a response to all
these hit pieces jokes taken out of
context and all that and I remember I
you know I knew Colin well enough for
the time to be like would you read this
and he he was like yeah it's a good
response I would take this one line out
it makes you sound like a [__] and I
was like all right so that was Colin
being like you know supportive as hell
yeah yeah it was early on it's fun it's
interesting to think about that like
it's because it's like history now
you're like wow yeah and you can see
every article wrote about me but they
were writing about me in the most like
uh passive aggressive way where they'd
be like Daniel Tosh uh oh you know did
it too but then a guy with no career Sam
Morrell uh did it and I was like all
right well I guess it's cool to get uh
even bad press hey it was it it kind of
worked that way yeah you got Montreal
yeah yeah no that I remember Robbie
Pratt who Netflix nabba ran Montreal all
the time was like there was no way I was
gonna you know let them win I was like
all right I mean whatever I'll take it
yeah yeah do you like my ACT yeah yeah
but I was appreciative that he said that
Tosh thing that was big that was big
that made the news big first big one
yeah it was around 2012 where it started
well what was the joke it was a Heckler
in there he did a rape joke rape joke
yeah and a woman was like that's not
funny by the way it killed and she's
like that's not funny and he goes
wouldn't it be funny if a bunch of guys
raped you right now and that killed me
too yeah not a bad line yeah and uh
that's a little aggressive that's a
little aggressive a little aggressive in
the moment but he was angry at her
because she interrupted the show and
they put it they played that on the news
so all these people are like can you
believe it and Bill Burr is the great
point he's like you can't take it out of
here and put it here where everyone else
sees it it's a different thing that's
like taking a stripper out of a strip
club and putting her on the but now
that's what the internet is right if you
put it tweet everyone's just like it's
not your audience it's not just your
Twitter people are over but I'm feeling
that already
I'll be right back
he's going to call his agent and scrub
this
well yeah you got drunk on a flight
that's fun it was it was fun man it was
cool to just be like up alone drunk dark
dark one in the morning my wife's just
passed out and I'm just like drinking
Prosecco and [__] you had a you had a
nice little sober uh well yeah so I I
just I stopped drinking for 60 days
until like a week ago whoa so I had like
60 days clean no hangover it felt
amazing you you're sharper oh dude
everything everything in your life is
better but then I was like then I was at
some outdoor you know thing with like
the hard cider over where we live and
live music and somebody's like you want
a hard cider I'm like yeah it's over
that turns into a hundred yeah yeah well
I'm just the one the thing with me is
and Giannis will tell you I can't when I
get the buzz when I get the wheels
greased
um nobody will Outlast me yeah I see oh
really nobody no no no nobody like when
I like I'll go seven eight in the
morning and like really steady do it
until everyone's down he's like a
franchise he's a franchise player
because he's got he's it's almost like
in an indomitable will it's like Jordan
wow yeah like like we even does it
despite like he wants to like despite
life and health no I just like the we
were Giannis is at the house we had a
little party he's turning three in the
morning everybody left where he's like
we're watching a doc at three in the
morning and I had lagavulin next to me
yeah and he just starts going and he
just saw me pouring it and he goes why
why I don't know we'll be like four in
the morning he's like why the [__] out
like I'll be falling asleep we've we've
had drinks all night and then I'll hear
a beer open he'll go to the fridge
we go why yeah
yeah thanks for watching we're done I'm
not proud of it but there is nobody that
will Outlast me interesting it's just I
just once once I get the wheels greased
I can't once you start drinking once I
start drinking I'll just it's just like
a marathon of like seven o'clock in the
morning I just don't want the party to
end but like everyone goes down so I'm
just alone I get that
Giannis is like yo let's watch a doc and
I think he's gonna actually watch it and
he's just snoring I'm pouring like a
villain by myself yeah a little smoky
but you like you like Smoky scotches
something are you still good I think I'm
pretty good what do you think yeah we
get we get banged up on the weekends on
the road that's my move yeah because you
can spot after show after shows right
yeah yeah I know I don't like it too
much to abuse it I I if I uh that's a
gentleman right there if I I don't want
to have to quit so I don't if if I get
to if I become so bad that I have to
quit then I don't ever get to drink
because that's what I'm monitoring I'm
the same way does the missing dad ever
come out when you get hammered
somebody go hey you were mean to me last
night sorry that's my dad left that's
when that comes out I don't think I'm a
mean drunk really no no no I mean he's
seen me [__] wasted a ton I mean yeah
you just get louder really yeah yeah and
you lean in you're like oh let me tell
you that
that's all positive it's all fun but
yeah Mark is like an old I feel like we
like drunks the way like they drink a
Madman minus a sexual assault right yeah
we just want to have fun we're just kind
of like yeah we're just drinking like
old school drinks we get lit up but
we're like we're pretty good I don't
think you drink during the day I won't
ever admit I'm drunk that's the problem
that's the fights I get in with like
women I'm dating I just will I'll be
like I'll come home like [__]
shit-faced and they'll be like you're
drunk I'm like I had two drinks like I
can't admit that I'm drunk that's a good
cop yeah I'm like I do but they're like
you you slurring your words they'll be
like I'm you think I'm drunk that's what
I'm like yeah that's where I pissed the
women off with like just the line where
I'm like I'm not drunk it's like that
city council did you see that uh yeah
what city he just got caught sleeping
his car with a crack pipe in his no way
oh dude he goes I'm napping I'm napping
he's holding it and he's just out cold
and he's just like oh dude what happened
he goes I'm napping and they go you have
a crack pipe in your hand you were uh
you were like dying while you're like
struggling to breathe he was like hey I
got sleep apnea he's holding a crack
fight and the funny part is when they
look at his idea and his badge and they
find out he's a city councilman and then
you see this moment of Hope in his face
like he's about to get up
you know he's like and the guy's like
nah you know it's we're on tape now you
got to go in yeah wow yeah he's out yeah
Rhode Island look look he tried moving
it yeah
oh he checks the shifter too
let's be on the plane last night wow I
would vote for this guy dude that's that
good crack sleep he was getting yes yeah
that nice REM cycle correctly it's a
portable CPAP yeah I would have almost
felt bad waking him up if I was that cop
I'm like that dude is having a good
crack sleep this happened to me in New
Orleans I got woken up by a crap
I was I don't know 17. I was my my
parents were out of town so I took my
dad's Lexus went to a crazy house party
got drunk said I could drive home woke
up on Martin Luther King Boulevard and
you know the Chris Rock joke if you want
Martin Luther King there's some violence
going down so whatever I'm asleep in the
Lexus sun's coming in knock on the
windshield
he's up he's alive somebody called him
and says a dead white kid and Alexis in
the projects holy so the cops swarmed
and I was like oh hey what's up officer
and they're like get out of the car get
out of the car and I'd piss myself and
it was leather seats so it was pooled it
just pulled so I get out there's a
puddle there I'm soaking wet guys give
me your ID that's wet the whole thing's
wet it's all covered in piss and they
look in the car somehow by the grace of
God I had taken the keys out of the
ignition and put them on the floor oh
thank God I don't know why and uh that's
why I didn't get a DUI holy yeah but I
had to walk home have you ever gotten a
DUI no you Sam I can't drive I I have a
license but I can't drive I got a
license on like a fluke New York that's
hilarious you guys can all you can but I
didn't I'd save New York like I didn't
start driving until I was like 28. wow
because I was Upstate yeah but I got it
but Upstate you got DUIs we got DUIs
because they would wait at the bar oh
and then everybody leave and they look
for an excuse I got I got a DUI I was 20
I was 21 and I was drinking Long Island
Iced Teas that'll do it and dude it was
two uh driveways from my bedroom like so
he pulled he pulled me up me and my
buddy go there I had like four long on
Ice teas I was hammered that's I think
what 20 drinks oh dude I was I was 20
beers different beers and I could have
walked but it was just like right around
so uh he was just hanging out he pulled
me over he goes yeah your uh license
plate bulb is out and then he looked at
my eyes
drinking and I go I did this [__] like
yeah you listen I'm gonna be honest with
you I had one
[Applause]
I had one and he goes yeah and he goes
what are you know and I go yeah I have
one beer and he goes and then I came out
and I feel like out of like 13 tests I
failed 11 of them and I go officer you
see that light right there it's true you
see that light red dog that's my bedroom
man I was like I'll leave the car here
can I just and he's like ah dude I gotta
take it oh
why do 13 tests when you fail that many
yeah are you just wasting time they're
like they ask you for letters they ask
you to walk they ask you to touch things
they ask you to walk and touch your nose
you do it all he's got like the chart
and he's like dude you failed everything
he's like do you like my penis you're
like no he's like that's another fail
unfortunately he's like that's 12.
13 does seem excessive dude I'm buzzing
my nuts off already this is wild
you know what Paul has he has like great
energy yeah good energy it's just like
good enthusiasm yeah
you know what that's why I'm a good Nick
fan yeah that's why I'm a good Nick fan
dude well you guys oh [__] that's
already hitting him
no because it's gonna be nine hours long
no because sorry sorry guys no because
you have that thing that a lot of Nick
fan Giannis jumped Jessica no no jump no
John is Jump [__] which I can't I love
it I'm here I love them you're still I
went to all three home playoff games
against the Heat yeah okay I took my son
against uh game three against the Cavs
it was incredible I I went I'm Die Hard
I'll support him I'll tell you what you
know what these uh finals have showed me
these Eastern Conference Finals show me
the Knicks with the second best team in
the East that's what that's right that's
what I've learned if Randall play better
the first you're very yeah you're and he
will next year you're loyal your loyalty
to the Knicks is baffling you're so only
the play it's your team it was my team
yeah but she's imagine jumping though
you jumped away from a team imagine I
did it yeah because it wasn't the way it
was an unhealthy relationship who are
you with now I'm nobody damn that just
shows you like yeah but when we when me
was so toxic that like I you're like the
Incredible Hulk just walking along the
highway just like yeah but dude when me
said when me Sam Jerry Ferrara are
crying what are you gonna do you know
what I mean like we're gonna have that
moment dude
it'll happen
you guys damn all right dude you're
hanging in there I love both of you I
love it I I dude I got my son Brunson
we're gonna be fine my son's like Dad
I'll die he's like I didn't because I
told him I said you'll never loved the
next morning he goes I'll give my life
for this
so when we lost when we lost my son my
son's like my wife when we when me and
my wife fight she drifts quietly when
they fight like me and my daughter get
it out now get it on the table now I
want to have a [__] good night get
out my son and and wife they migrate
away process it yeah so the Knicks lost
he just he put a hoodie up and he just
goes up to his room and I go what's up
man let's watch the Laker game and he
just give me a second and dude he went
in and he just sat in his room and he
just he he was tearing he was crying and
then and then he came downstairs and he
sat there and he processed it
but you know what I felt like I'm a good
father man yeah yeah I'm a good father
dude you gotta you gotta roll with it
yeah wow
you can't jump shipyon I've I've been
jump ship I'm way out well guess what
we'll welcome you back anytime I told
him that it feels like I'm like uh you
know you missed out in a hell of a year
you missed out on a hell of a year buddy
Scientology it's wild dude this is our
year Leah Remini and Randall's the
answer and Jalen bro we're not
kidnapping anybody we're not violent
people yeah we're not kidnapping family
members people New Yorkers we're good
people well the Jets are worse the Jets
are it's masochism yeah yeah he's got
Aaron Rodgers you never know that's true
yeah yeah all right New York Sports baby
we're alive we're well the Rangers gonna
be back next year New York Sports are
back on the [__] match there you go
let's go Liberty
after we give you a beating for it
that's [__] loser Behavior stick with
the hat there you go
there we go you look like this picture
should be on a [__] mug shot
somewhere all right
you should be a wanted registered sex
offender side on the street with this
image right here it looks like a crack
pipe should be in his hands
you like the naval team
you know what a happy guy yeah oh yeah
you're like really [__] him yeah he does
look happy that's a that's like a guy
that you want in your corner you like a
Nick fan like that you're a Nick fan I'm
a Nick and a Met fan so I'm Loser yeah
that's right man you never do you never
know man come on Steve Cohen is I'm a
Yankees fan but Steve Cohen's a great I
think he's a great honor I think I think
it's gonna I think things could turn
around Bill Maher sold his net his Mets
uh whatever his stock he was invested in
the Mets Bill Maher yeah Bill Maher
watching the match oh okay I'm gonna
make another error really you believe in
God
okay
there's only two pronouns okay
I do I do like that show he kind of
flip-flopped big time he's all over the
road now he's a little I feel like he's
like he went like almost conservative a
little bit would you say yeah
he still left he just shits on the left
a lot yeah he's giving us more ammo you
know more comedy yes yeah the left got
silly it got silly yeah silly you know
it's a good lady jerking off in a
bathroom there's all kinds of stuff
going on with the left you're looking
like some of this catch relief stuff
it's it's hilarious like the um the new
laws and like San Francisco now New York
like if you steal some it's like oh yeah
a thousand dollars of merchandise you
gotta apologize to them for having
merchandise right right how is society
failed you like how much Target is
losing every year yeah yeah yeah now
it's just like uh what has how has
Society failed here dude Adrian
appellucci had that great joke when she
opened for Louis the garden when she
said it did trans family shooting a
transgender person killing a family and
then people going how bad they feel for
them so it must be so hard for you what
you're going through after this is so
damn she's great she's got great stuff
yeah Louie picked her up because she had
that bit about uh well not literally
it's tough to pick her up that's true
although he scooped her or started using
her sorry because she had that joke
about the uh the Catholic schools they
put the uh oh the Ash and he's like
looks like Target practical Shooters
Louie's like who's this gal my new
opener yeah there you go yeah she's got
great I mean she's got one of my
favorite jokes of all time the one about
how her boyfriend threatened it I'm
probably set on the Pod before but my
boyfriend's trying to kill himself and I
was like wait now I can't kill myself or
people gonna think we were in love
that's a great show brilliant that's
like a perfect yeah perfect one-liner
yeah you can't write a better joke
especially when you know it's about
Chris Italian
that's [__] hilarious that's perfect
there's like zero fat it's just yeah
well not on Natalia but yeah
sometimes that's all that matters
yeah
these drinks are [__] hitting bro
dude no dude I'm [__] down I got shows
of that this is our second episode today
so we are gonna be [__] up oh [__] but
you know what it just might be hey
rocket money we love right we were just
talking about these guys inflation's on
the rise we're looking for new ways to
save money well one of those ways is
rocket money rocket money is your
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and spit and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place most Americans
think they spend about eighty dollars on
subscriptions a month well the total is
actually closer to 200. Rocket money
quickly and easily finds your
subscriptions and cancels anything you
no longer want Jesus Christ where's this
been all my life I got all these
companies up my ass they're charged me
and I don't even know about it they prey
on my ignorance
so thank you [__] Jeffrey Epstein or
something yes exactly pieces of [__]
yeah [__] you you [__] yeah
yeah I'm still being charged for going
to the island it also helps you manage
your finances by categorizing your
expenses so you can see where your
paycheck is going the average user saves
up to 720 per year and over three
million people have used rocket money to
get a handle on their budgets stop
throwing your money away cancel on one
of subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com
drunk that's rocketmoney.com drunk
rocketmoney.com thank you
hey folks fume we're brought to you by
fume we all have bad habit or two fume
lets you remove the bed while keeping
the Habit make it a much easier
transition on your brain and body fume
is an Innovative device that replaces
that nasty hand amount habit you've been
wanting to do less of with no
electronics fume is completely natural
there's no Vapor or harmful chemicals
fume just uses air and all-natural
delicious flavors like white cranberry
and crisp mint
we love fume it's fun to hold it's fun
to suck on it's fun to just have and it
it just kills that craving you know when
you just want to put something in your
mouth you hear that wife
with an adjustable airflow dial and
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
fume helps reduce stress and anxiety
while you break your habit
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching the fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over a hundred thousand customers
and has thousands of success stories and
there's no reason that can't be you join
fume and accelerating Humanities break
up from destructive Habits by picking up
the journey pack today head to fume.com
and use promo code drunk to save 10 off
when you go to get the journey pack
today that's try fum.com and use code
drunk to save an additional 10 off your
order today fume
so you guys uh you're just doing the
YouTube train with these specials or
what yeah I did two of them I think my
next one I'm gonna do that yeah I'm
gonna do that yeah Sal vulcano's doing a
YouTube he's got all the fans in the
world he's like [__] on you Youtube
Rogan's doing it YouTube clips it's
Clips too man it's like it's crazy how
it changed yeah I think I'm gonna do the
YouTube one I love it now because nobody
would touch us so we're like well we'll
put it on here yeah why not the game has
changed people are making movies just
doing like people yeah like it's it's
going to that place now good where
you're just gonna be able to I mean
obviously you're gonna have to have
money but you can invest in a cast and
you can invest in the cameras and make a
movie dude you know what the industry
feels like it feels like the girl who
was hot in high school and now she's
like put on a few pounds she's got a
little older and she's like wait wait
and then you come back and she's like
you gotta wait six months for me to
reply to a text yeah you yes yeah yeah
no it's uh that's the problem is like
now with the writer strike too we've
talked about this but you know things
took long before this [__] like for them
to be like okay we have to talk to
another just try setting a meeting with
an industry so I said in a meeting
they're like okay is three weeks out
from now and you're like what yeah three
you don't have a window before three
weeks that's to meet
and then you're like okay well
brainstorm yeah then you're like well
how about I pitch something that's in uh
eight weeks yeah exactly no it's dude
it's so true man projects are we were
supposed to get something done by
January and that and it still wasn't
done and then the writer strike happened
it's like it's but people are getting
hit harder than us I mean well thank God
we have stand up you know I mean like
the writers right now that's that's some
[__] that's your bread and butter
you know everybody it's just like pay
the writers pay the [__] writers yeah
it's like every every show that you love
that you say is great is because of
these writers just pay them no I know
yeah I think with it all the time you
know uh I re-watch I I don't watch as
many new shows as I should I just kind
of re-watch shows I already love like
Sopranos Mad Men the y or [__] like that
and like you watch these shows you're
like why do I love this show it's a
[__] I mean of course the accident
well right of course like right you know
the the filmmaking is great all that
stuff but the writing is really no it's
everything why are you there yeah that's
the arc that's the you know why the
actors get to be so good yeah yeah I was
talking to uh Brad Garrett about
everyone loves Raymond and he's like
dude he's like as great as we got you
know chemistry and stuff he's like the
writers did all of that but he's a
humble guy he's like a really good guy
he's like incredibly like like he's so
talented he's a funny guy but nobody's
it's I think a lot of it too is just
nobody's watching either and then look
at the tick tock the the amount of time
on Tick Tock versus even Netflix
streaming services Tick Tock is like
it's non-committal yeah you have to
commit to a show whereas Tick Tock you
just 10 seconds next yeah 10 seconds so
then you're on the same amount of time
but that time was it was like you went
in without a commitment right but that
also that hurts us too though that'll
hurt us too if you want to put something
out that you worked on for a long time
that's long-winded now you got kids just
going like I want to see 19 seconds of
it you know thing about comedians is
we're like rats and roaches we will
adapt yes we'll find a way in we do so
whatever like hurt will also help us
because we'll find a way it'll kill a
few of us right but the co-headline with
AI yeah it'll be Giannis Mauricio and
artificial intelligence
there was like there was comics on
rooftops like Parks Yards parking
everywhere like it just we're like
roaches we survive that's true yeah we
figured out yeah that's why we ever meet
those Comics we're like I don't go to
that room anymore because they don't get
me and you're like you're not gonna make
it yeah because you've got to be able to
just figure it out yeah or make it work
or like I'm not going there to [__]
do that I'm not it's like uh dude you
gotta play the game a little bit a
little bit you know gotta hit some
cities that might make you uncomfortable
yeah yeah you know you gotta you gotta
hit everything I mean I've done Bagels
I've done a bagel store in my life I've
done
I mean I've performed comedy I actually
do better in the bagel stores yeah right
I mean we've do the rooms we did coming
up like I remember there was a laundry
mat show oh yeah oh yeah I did a show at
an apartment yo many of those yeah I
remember when like someone would see you
at a club and then hire you for a
private birthday yes and it's a horrible
idea but they're giving you at that time
like 500 bucks or a thousand bucks and
you do it you just go in and you're in
someone's [__] living room uh I did
that six people on a couch and you're
like all right here we go yeah yeah
you're just counting them I walked
around a pool when a kid graduated from
high school and I just had a wireless
round of school in Jersey it was [__]
horrible Christmas parties and DJ stops
you're like here we and nobody's
listening yeah the worst dude I just did
a corporate gig I haven't bombed that
bad since the 80s it was brutal brutal
and it was the worst thing too I did
this corporate gang guys like I'm a huge
fan I watch everything you do I know all
you're at can you do this joke he knows
I know my whole act so I'm like I'm
killing this this guy knows my whole act
he loves me he's like do whatever you
want no restrictions it's a bunch of
crazy real estate million airs up there
they don't they don't get offended I was
like great I go up there you know
immediately the feedback like out of a
movie the [__] mic's going crazy and
I open with a couple things about a guy
in the front row and they're like
no yeah all right I'll go into my ACT no
anything we need to set up and like talk
about a bit or like have a you know it's
like a a premise to it they were out but
if I called him gay that would kill well
that's what's frustrating too with those
gigs I mean obviously not getting paid
like it's a regular show hey it was
great yeah but at the same time you do
those gigs and I remember like you'll go
into a store you're like well this story
works for my crowd and then you're like
well my crowd pays attention they don't
pay attention they don't pay you need to
hit them quick I'm like this bit like it
needs like it builds and it builds and
it builds but it doesn't hit in the
first three minutes you're [__] yes so
you're like us and the worst thing with
the guy who hired me was like sitting in
the front row and he could he was
looking at me like do it what are you
doing oh that's the word like oh boy I
love you
dude it was a nightmare I did a private
for a guy he literally sent my like a
special of mine to all his friends
coming like you're gonna love this guy
even though they just didn't give a [__]
they were like yeah of course I don't
give a [__] this is the guy they're like
all right I don't know I love those
games
the GPS tells you to take the tunnel and
there's traffic in the tunnel and then
you go back take the bridge just
trapping at the bridge it's like I'll do
crowd work and that doesn't work there
you go back
there's [__] traffic everywhere and
you think on the way home what could you
have done and there's nothing that you
could have done it was just traffic
everywhere there was this uh there was
this country club gig in there like hey
man they're giving an award out they
give it every year to this guy he goes
he's a billionaire his wife's name is
Lindsey rostam talk about how she's got
faked I swear she's gonna talk about how
she's got talk about how she's got fake
tits and talk about this and he's got
all this money so I'm up there and I'm
kind of dying and it's all it's all just
one percenters yeah like ice sculptures
and people just carving meat off of a
thing and they just came off a golf
course and they're all smoking cigars
right so then I finally go where's
what's his name the guy winning the
award
and I just collect this I go yeah this
guy man talk about his money I go he's
got his hands on a lot of paper and
plastic and I go and by plastic I mean
his wife Lindsay's tits and everyone
just goes whoa no
[Laughter]
all right
so anyway then I started making fun of
Chris Christie and I started calling him
a fat I started doing and somebody
somebody said he somebody leaned over
Jason lawhead was there somebody goes
hey man we just threw Chris Christie a
three thousand dollar a plate uh
fundraiser uh last weekend in South
Carolina and I started [__] on him
and one old man he was 80. he was like
all right all right like in other words
wow yeah and I had I had a check
for two thousand dollars in my pocket I
walked off stage into the parking lot
and I just texted the other comic I go
in the car wow it was fun it was brutal
yeah well I feel funny you don't know
you're like ruining your career with
like roasting this bill like Rose's
billionaire like sir [__] on some guy
you're like who is it like uh Jeff Bezos
yeah that's my life yeah also if it was
three thousand dollars a play Chris
Christie and he must have spent 40 Grand
yeah I've had corporate guy I did a
corporate for big Pharma and man did I
die and he's one of those bombs where
you're like that worked on The Tonight
Show you know when you're like bitter
now because you've been bombing for 12
minutes and like nothing's working and
then I eventually hit on a guy's wife or
attacked a guy's wife she starts crying
it's the [__] CEO's wife so he has to
run out and save her and they're like
the guy comes back he's like cut it cut
it so they replaced me mid-show what's
big farm I can get her Samantha
depressants I'm sure it'll be okay I
know I made a lot of those jokes I was
like you guys are [__] drug dealers
[__] off you notice how it's always the
great gigs with money that are just the
worst thing you just say no to him it's
just like no they're like hey you want
to do a Christmas party so much money
yeah yeah all right yeah start the car
you just start the car and that's it the
jokes and bomb it up and leave yeah I
remember I bombed a a private event once
so hard and I ran into uh mullaney at
The Comedy Cellar right after and I was
like how you doing I was like and he's
like I'm great how you doing
what's going on
I found a private and he goes he goes
he cheered me up he was like yo you know
everyone bombing one of those I I think
about uh how do you think about what I'm
gonna buy
[Laughter]
I was like what the [__] you just don't
see that like you never saw that way
back to our point before yeah the
cleaner comes like Yeah the more
together someone seems even he said that
I saw him on some podcasts talking about
he's like isn't it always that way even
he was admitting because I think it was
Theo Vaughn yeah that was a great I
would have never thought it was you and
he was like but that isn't that always
what it is exactly you think is the
opposite together and you're exactly it
always is kind of like every time there
was a Serial rape there was a serial
rapist who was cleaner than Cosby yeah
he would go down champ and they looked
at they got him by looking at his
schedule yeah because he was just raping
like raping girls tour it matched up
matched up with his tour and he was like
squeaky clean oh yeah yeah and he would
give Comics [__] about their cursing
it's just like Cosby it's a Cosby yeah
you got to get it out so that's so weird
you got to get it out somewhere yeah
well when you go that extreme it's like
why what are you hiding yeah it's like
there's a reason for it I always well to
be clean is one thing but then it scold
other people for not being yeah yeah
that's that's when I'm becoming a little
suspicious yeah another one being clean
yeah it definitely opens you up for more
it's that holier than thou it's it's
been talked about to death but
politicians same [__] I mean when you
when you're doing the whole thing like
you know gays shouldn't have this and
you're like dude just let's let's just
skip this scene real quickly yeah until
you [__] [__] a dude yeah yeah this
is your credit card let me see your
credit card bill why were you at the
Super 8 what's going on
a motel yeah it's cheap it's quick and
there's no reason to be that mad about
it exactly there's no reason to be like
that how could you be with another man
if it's like why would you why are you
getting like that yes oh you're
projecting your own [__] that's why I
love the like people who cancel people
and then people start looking [__] up
they're like oh yeah the baby in 1981
yeah you know you choked out a baby
there's always something especially when
they're mad about the drag queens
dancing I'm like they're dancing right
who gives a [__] yeah but the kid I mean
why are dry why are why are drag queens
doing Story Hour it started in Texas and
it and it became wildly popular and then
other people oh it's my drag queen alarm
it is a weird mix even like a long short
long shortens are teaching kids you know
like that's a weird one too I don't
dislike Longshore yeah because it's a
nightclub act I mean that's the weird
thing it shouldn't even be there
shouldn't even be comedy shows at
kindergarten
showed up I'd be like what the [__] yeah
yeah yeah well if you're a comic and
you're performing for kindergarteners
you're a [__] you've got a brain
injury yeah yeah why are you yeah what
are you doing is that your act yeah
you're not a cop but it is weird for
like a drag a grown man to dress and
drag and go to a first grade school like
that
very strange sure yeah kindergarten I
always think about them like I wouldn't
even want a comedy show coming to my
kids of course of course and it's weird
almost showing up at my
daughter's second grade I'm like whoa
and he's got kids yeah and he's got kids
he'd be like nah I don't want him to
watch the show well I was Dre I was
raised by a drag queen our Nanny's was a
big drag guy big black guy in a wig and
all that and like really he didn't do it
at the [__] going on in New Orleans
well that's New Orleans it's Lawless you
know but wait a minute that was like
your babysitter yeah it was like he
cleaned the house but he would also take
kind of take care of me and my brother
well my parents my parents were
Workaholics yeah so he was always there
and he taught me how to drive a stick he
taught me how to shave but he had a wig
on and high heels but it was just normal
and my parents were like you know cool
it with the drag act like they wouldn't
want him being like bada boom boom you
know but he was still a hell of a nanny
wait they told him to cool it like like
yeah like they didn't want him uh but
they hired him and they were like they
hired him he was a good guy he was a
great dude but he it was they didn't
want him to wear the heels no no they
were fine with the heels just don't
don't like dance it up don't get the boa
out and do all that was it like bizarre
seeing a guy with authority with like
high heels on talking he got used to it
pretty quick actually and now I can't
get hard unless I see a picture of
RuPaul
hahaha
but it's still weird like other friends
would come over like what the [__] up
with this guy I'm like Ah that's just
anus you know he's cool that's a true
thing true story yeah he was eventually
killed because he's hooked up with a guy
in a in a van and the guy thought he was
a woman and the Dick came out oh a
little Street just possible was it
passable no but you know you get a
couple of verzies out there and uh were
you like were you [__] up over that a
little I was I was in college by that
point so that must have been I mean that
was like a guy who helped raise you it
was crazy yeah it was the whole big
thing with the family that's interesting
yeah true story did you go to the
funeral no funeral no family no family
yeah and we gave him that van that was
our van that we gave them did you get it
back yeah we didn't get the van back
there's a lot of blood who with your
parents that they hired a drag queen
they're very open they're like the most
liberal open-minded southern people ever
that's it yeah New Orleans people are
interesting very weird eccentric
eccentric know for sure it's almost like
not American the city it almost feels
like foreign you know like a mix of
Frenchy people sure yeah French are
always into something weird oh yeah yeah
and it's a lot of black influence so
it's a good mix well the French are
weirdly like judgmental but also
open-minded yeah yeah the kids are
drinking wine smoking
yeah they're like way cooler about like
Affairs and stuff oh they're very sexual
people remember when there was a metoo
thing started the French had the not me
movement
all right yeah we're like we're the
opposite we're like not cool about sex
but like shoot [__] up we want to oh
yeah yeah diving gun guy shits the gold
nugget that's every American movie yeah
we're very repressed yeah
and then you watch their movies it's
like everyone's making out everyone's
having Affairs yeah you know it's it's
uh that's what about the the super left
now like I'll do shows for like super
Lefty and they're almost Christian
conservative like oh how dare you and
I'm like you guys are like Nancy Reagan
yeah out here it's very strange they're
like supposed to be the people who watch
them yeah they're supposed to be the
people that are like that like
proverbially whipping themselves like
where's the uh did you say trance they
can't like smile they're like where's
the open-minded yeah and all that yeah
they're nervous they feel like they're
complicit yeah rather than just seeing a
show and yeah
should we do some news
here we go from Gilligan
are you guys buzzing like that oh yeah
second show yeah we're buzzing baby this
guy said he could go all night he's like
[__] up listen don't get I mean don't
get it don't tease him he's one of those
dudes I think gets drunk by the second
drink but can have 40 drives yeah yes I
think he's one of those
so all right
we'll get one of these in the studio
uh is Dyson's air purifying a Bane mask
a breath of fresh air see my wife has
breathing problems so I'm gonna get this
for her but really it'll just double as
a she can't talk all right it's hard
enough to meet a person now they're
wearing this [__] and you know I thought
we were done with masks yeah yeah we
should be done like when I see a person
wearing it just looks ridiculous that's
illegal now yeah I almost feel
threatened I'm like are they about to
rob a store that's open you can't just
oh yeah sure you should have to paint
the rest of their face on there so you
can be identified because you're like oh
now you're a bandit right right dude LAX
yesterday packs with masks really oh
yeah yeah it's interesting well if
they're Asian I let it slide no these
were like actually I saw all different
like black couples walking masks
interesting I thought it was gonna be
like no these are actually normal people
these are people you don't want to be
violent against it is where the Bane
mask these were real people that's a
weird it's a weird people
I don't understand like him is this you
wear this out in public or do you wear
this at home only well we have a cat and
my wife's alert to cats yeah but she
just loves cats and she's allergic it's
kind of a weird throw that thing on yeah
I was like should I get you this she's
like well look at this she can't
slapping it up too like throw the dices
on you [__] yeah exactly
stop yapping okay there's another star
here uh this China's backlash against
the comedy uh against a comedy I saw
this [__] there's fear of a clamp down
one joke by a Chinese comedian military
yeah fear of a clamp down
you're in China you're like whoa things
are getting a little sensory
where's our daughter yeah
you can't even you're not allowed to
look at the internet over there
a two million dollar fine a police probe
and a sweep of canceled shirts two
million dollar fine what the [__] is
wrong with this comic dude know your
audience yeah right [__] yeshivin do
Holocaust jokes I would actually but
yeah sure you could do it but it's like
you're in China death to the West jokes
that happened Chinese jokes yeah yeah
that's it what are you crazy we move
here and open for Ellie Wong yeah well
you know this is like they do they say
uh something like it's somewhat free
speech in China I'm like well that ain't
Free Speech it's like it's free speech
in China the way it's like free speech
with your girlfriend
it's like there's certain [__] you can
say and then [__] we were like yeah I'm
[__] right right they're not allowed
to search certain things on Google like
yeah wow yeah they can't it's they can't
get on sites and stuff and they have a
limited amount of time with Tick Tock
which is weird because they invented it
they must be so annoyed with us
complaining what we could talk about
it's completely cool it's like
engineering videos science stuff yeah
and we're just like work
14 too old
[Laughter]
this is sad I mean China was already
[__] up this is a new low main yep
they got it done a long time ago yep I
wonder if there's still someone in China
like cancel culture's not real you're
like [__] I gotta pay 2 million over
here
absolutely in China our podcast is
called they're totally not drunk yeah
known better and just like know your
audience man well you know vir da sees
an Indian comic he's got like 12
lawsuits going there it's insane yeah
great if you haven't heard of your dad's
episode great episode I mean crazy
fascinating crazy it's not going to be a
comic that changes it though no no it's
not gonna be like there's not gonna be
no comic who's up there who changes the
culture I don't know dude Lenny Bruce he
pushed back I mean he did that it was it
was conservative right back then now
it's the left true dick jokes Jesus died
for us to be able to say [__] [__]
and [__] and stuff like that yeah
[__] yeah that's what he went to
jail for what [__] yeah in China
the stand-up comedy is a rare refuge for
free speech yeah but we say that [__]
here it's the last Bastion yeah the only
time you hear the word Bastion do you
know in those kind you know in like um
in Scandinavian countries they kind of
look down at comedians
um they kind of look they look down
comedians here yeah but I mean like not
like not like blue collar like regular
people but I feel like the industry like
we're the lowest oh yeah show business
for sure but I mean we still get to be
stars and people like excited over there
they're like you're commute you know
they look down because they're so
educated and they just yeah it's not a
lofty profession thank you interesting
thank you so much well I mean it's kind
of like how it was in the you know the
course
I love it yeah I think they kind of
accurate they more accurately see us for
who we are yeah yeah it's like we're
still a guy who's you know you're a guy
who [__] his pants in New Orleans
exactly your dad's dude yeah
your dad also didn't say
[__] broken toys yeah yeah but that's
what's fun we're having a good time
that's really I mean that's the thing
it's like this is a fun life oh yeah
it's great I'd rather be here than there
I don't want the celebrity I don't want
to be [__] no Comics are the most
down-earth people they really are really
close that's what makes it when you got
you guys be getting successful it's
tough it's weird it sounds like weird
looking I don't like it I want to go
back yeah it is a blue car blue collar
art form yeah really because you got to
just grind grind grind go back to work
go back to work fail it's a lot of
failure but weirdly like but even like
if you think about it even like being a
Broadway actor is weirdly like blue
collar the sheet the work you have to do
the work ethic you have to have is
insane yeah but they're throwing them
flowers and [__] of course it's a
different energy
but but there's someone doing Othello
like in a bar outside of New Hampshire
fair enough fair enough but I'm just
saying like the the work you have maybe
Blue Collar is the wrong word but like
the work ethic you have to put in yeah I
mean have you ever gone like a Broadway
show these dudes are oh that's
incredible insane it's incredible I feel
like they get respect they have
assistance they work out they only do
six months out of the year I think it's
a little more pampered fair enough we
can go on drunk there's a difference but
that's true yeah but I don't know the
thing when I did America's Got Talent
I'm like these people like stretching
and they're like trying to get ready I'm
like I'm like two beers in yeah all
right yeah sometimes we go up with no
show sometimes yeah yeah it's like we
are kind of the lowest we're just like
we go up there and talk yeah sometimes
we're not even doing jokes we're just
like where are you yeah but one yeah but
we also forget though you also forget
sometimes you have a a killer bit or
like that bit you said like that about
Adrian with that thing
um brilliant yeah so like sometimes it's
a really smart so the whole thing of
like traveling clowns I was talking
maybe Brett Ernst or somebody like oh
we're clowns it's like yeah well clowns
really don't make you think I think
something that's really true comedians
make a good bit or something that really
you know as much as you want to say it's
a low art form did you it's a smart
thing I love how it bothers you with it
the lower no no no it's Pride yeah
that's a sicilian no no but here's the
thing no but here's the thing because
soda soda was on soda was on a podcast
we're talking it was like you know
because Jessica's like I'm a traveling
clown or I'm gonna try and sort of okay
we're traveling class I go yeah but
clowns don't make you think all the time
I agree and you could do a bit like
Richard I'm looking at Richard Pryor has
done things where you're just like dude
that's so [__] brilliant that that's
you could say it's the lowest form but
not many people are doing that yeah yeah
and how many people on the road go like
you got me through them my mom died you
got me through it yeah I like being I
like being thought of as a traveling
clown and then hopefully exceeding
expectations yes
will they raise us up and then we have
to then they're like that's it yeah
like almost us not liking compliments
yeah and saying so you're just like but
you are kind of when somebody goes hey
man that one bit dude is so funny and I
really love that's a that's a thing dude
that's the social service we do we're
social workers
you sounded very Jewish one you said
that social workers Social Services
Social Service we're doing are you are
you finishing the news first
[Music]
this is a weird mix of uh producers you
got we got a whole thing you got like
the typical football yeah a drunk sailor
and a metrosexual Jersey bartender
there's a three random male generic
stereotypes
the Common Thread oh dude that would
have been all right well they got to be
on time yeah you should get your Nick
fret like your Nick friend comic friends
here and watch Nick's like game and do
it and call it real in real time that'd
be fun dude that would be fun that would
be pretty fun
all right a teacher in Florida is under
investigation for misconduct on this God
these kids today got it made under the
states don't say gay laws after they
showed the film strange world oh
I don't even I don't even I don't know
the movie I've never heard of the movie
but every Disney movie has a gay
character Jafar uh basically every
villain is they're all gay well that one
executive admitted it there was one
there was one uh woman executive she
goes listen she goes I wanted to put you
know I wanted to put that in in there
and like it she was getting some like
you know some kind of you know I guess
backlash a little bit oh this is a
little inclusive with some games because
I think she might be she might be a
lesbian she might be a lesbian so she
wanted the characters to be like her and
stuff like that but it's a news story I
mean it has like are they eating each
other's ass or is they're just a gay
character right how do they know the
character is gay like right he might say
it I mean you could watch a Disney
like how do you but yeah but that's the
thing it's like they shouldn't be
talking about sex in Disney movies so
it's like yeah it's assuming the
characters
but yeah they're all good and the Seven
Dwarves uh you know scar from a lion
king it is weird sexual [__] is
happening around kids you can't kind of
deny that that that's kind of a you know
like we were talking about before with
the drag queen thing it's around kids a
bit it's weird Mark and I aren't dead
you guys are dads I mean yeah I I don't
know for me I just like I don't really
watch kids movies here's the deal I I
thought it was like because
no I'm joking yeah I was in Jersey doing
a show it was like during the pandemic
it was an outdoor show and I saw one I
saw I actually saw what it was like
seeing a a bobcat what I saw a drag
story out oh I saw one live what yeah
it's like seeing a bobcat or or a black
person in our neighborhood it's like
whoa I finally saw it like and so I
watched it and uh unless you got
firsthand experience I wasn't seeing it
I gotta say disturbing it felt forced
right it felt weird it felt like what is
going on it just makes a little kid go
what is Mommy why was that man dressed
like that there's that that's an honest
question well here's what here's what I
witnessed I Witnesses the kids being
kids right yeah but you know here's what
I say to that why is that man dressed
like that I grew up in New York City
it's like who gives a [__] I'd see that
all the time and I would and my mom
would just say well that's how they are
well this is why I agree with you I
didn't have like a moral objection to it
per se it just felt forced
but I guess the question is why is it at
school it wasn't at school it was an
outdoor event so I don't know if it was
affiliated with school but it was
definitely drag queen guest themed like
Story Time and music and like there's
kids it felt it does feel like a pushing
of a thing right right you know like
oppressed people do that they get a
little louder we're here now they're
like wanna sure because you go the kids
are not paying attention the kids are
being kids yeah the kids were all like
looking at each other playing around
running around and you just saw these
drag queens like trying to get their
attention but kids are like picking
their nose yeah [__] at each other
because they're four right they don't
want to watch a concert yes and so it's
just like and the parents were like
overly going like yeah
for the parents where were you this was
in New Jersey well they're kind of
signaling like we're on board exactly
yeah because I think that's the type of
parent who brings their kid to that
event I was like I want people to see me
with my kid here yes because there's
gonna be no neon Nazis in my periphery
right we're an accepting family we're
sending a message it's fake yeah like
fake the force thing it's like when you
watch a movie where the the female star
is beating up all the guys you're like I
get what we're doing here we have to
pretend like this lady can fight 38
dudes who are bigger than that and
nobody's mad at drag drag queens no it's
just that doing that pushing it at the
school it doesn't seem necessary that's
a nightclub act you know what's funny is
like is it what is it when people say
it's pushed in schools what does that
mean there there was a whole thing
called the drag uh School in New York
there's a drag queen Story Hour or
something where they go to schools and
they do it on ferries and they like
fairies drag queens read books to kids
yeah drag queens will come in and
they'll do like splits and they'll be
like hey kids you know what's funny
though is you know how honest kids are
when they're young they're like a little
me I love that you know there's gonna be
some kid going you're a man with a dress
mom's going don't say that
the kids just sound like an anchor on
Fox that's all it is
oh my God I think he just got an hour
show that's a crazy looking drag queen
though they don't all have to look that
insane by the way
but yeah all right
that's fun it's dragstoryhour.org so it
is weird types yeah it is happening we
should book one we should be interested
I'd love to ask questions I'm curious
hey I would love it it's fun drag shows
are fun but I do understand other
people's points of like why in school I
do of course I understand that and my
point again I'll just because I know
people may get upset my point is just
like I wouldn't even want comedy in a
squad right nothing that's like right it
just seems pushed and forced when it's
not necessary it's not against them it's
for adults yeah yeah I hear you you know
drag queens don't go out there with like
librarian outfits on sure you know was
there like a Wesley Snipes movie with
drag queens when they ran off the bar
with uh thank you for Everything Julie
Newmar never seen it
yeah no it's a fun movie Wesley Snipes
Kurt Russell and I think John Leguizamo
I don't know it yeah it was it was a
show in the 90s or a movie tonight yeah
drag queens
Good Times
all right we got a twitch streamer went
viral after being banned from the place
now we're talking for running a queefing
for Subs live stream oh my God we should
get her in here I want to challenge her
with some some farts yeah dude that's
like how isn't that how like Howard
Stern got big ratings what's the problem
here I don't know I don't get it let her
queef yeah
that's a good shirt let her queef yeah
I'm Pro quit what did you find this
article The Wall Street Journal where
are we pulling this from I have Pop
Crush
what the hell what are we getting these
articles by the way griefing for Subs
did the captain just [__] die where
is he and you know undo the boat he
didn't come back yeah is that the
schooner
yeah but no I mean you know I don't it's
with it you're not allowed to queef on
Twitch it's twitch yeah who gives a
[__] fart but you can't do that yeah
what's it what why yeah what about only
fans is that the same thing or no that's
where she went to go uh queef it up
sweep it up yeah good for her kuif
Latifah that's her a handle on Twitter
you want to look her up this is American
again it's like you go and you watch
like uh nine uh 9-1-1 call videos yeah
and there's no problem but if you queef
it's like it's you got to get banned I
saw one of the tweets it was like we
need to normalize women do it I'm like
normalize this isn't MLK like what maybe
dial it back a little
the leaps are great though I love it she
farts yeah I mean they are it means
you're doing well I think I mean I don't
know if I would call him great well
they're not bad they should teach kids
how to clean they're funny unless your
dick causes one okay cause one that
means there's a lot of air around it
yeah well now you just ruined my day
King a queef is sort of like a small
dick alarm the more they queef that
means your dick is not really filling up
what you need to be really yeah
damn it
damn it I haven't heard a queef in years
by the way I I quit every time
I've heard a few all right yeah you're
doing all right downtown I'm avarage all
right that's what I thought I was yeah
[Music]
I love when guys I never had any
complaints it's like a woman's gonna go
ah I'd like to make I speak to a manager
here
two more inches of dick
two more fingers would you take a bigger
dick or go in longer or like bigger dick
bigger dick dude what kind of question
bigger dick or what like if you had a oh
yeah no one cares
that's like from her perspective I'll
take the bigger dick I don't care if I
last one yeah no but I'm talking about
like you can't give like you know how
depressing it's gonna be for you to
every time every time you're gonna do 20
20 seconds I could still eat her [__] I
don't have to use my dick for that and
you can jerk off before and get a Viagra
the last thing longer thing is like
almost a nuisance yeah well too big wait
a minute though it's like I don't go too
big really like you want to give us if
you last two one though then she's like
annoyed how often do you want to go like
well she's trying to talk sexy like I
want you to come and you're like you're
you're not enjoying this no I know
there's a lot of them what do you think
the average is like six seven minutes
average
average six seven minutes depends it
depends on a condom or no condom there's
a lot of factors how hot the girl is
yeah you know how drunk you are that's a
big one that's a big one you want Coke
is she making fun of you for being
adopted there's a lot of factors here
about whether or not you're coming right
is there stubble showing did I say it
out loud is she a drag queen
the wheelchair you know what's funny is
when like you uh you try to ignore
stereo the truth is stereotypes but you
just it's in your face and you can't
help it true for a reason like I played
basketball I'd be in the locker room and
it's just
it's true the black did I mean it's just
it's crazy they're Jess uncomfortably
big sometimes yeah and I've never seen
you know I've seen like big white dicks
they're out there Derek they can be up
there but like when they're big
it's like they're black when they're
like whoa yeah yeah for sure but maybe
it's just my tiny dick talk but I've
heard a lot of ladies like that the big
ones they heard they can't it's a myth
we don't like it yeah that could be just
I don't know but this is why I proposed
yeah
but I mean dude I there's I've seen some
uncomfortably big black dicks oh yeah
it's crazy it's like it's just on my
desktop yeah
but also there's some some math involved
too where you're like all right I'm
looking at that guy's dong it's 46
inches but how long till we hit the
sternum here of a lady you know like how
far can you really put that they only
have logistically yeah no well Theo
Vaughn actually uh had a theory in the
culture he feels like the dicks
correlate to the ad size
I've heard this from a black guy I heard
this yeah yeah it was like I don't know
if that's a theory I thought it was
funny but then I I was I gave it some
good the theory like he's Isaac Newton I
don't know if that's a theory
square look at her ass yeah lazy Asian
that's it that's what he said the Asian
small no asses flat well women's white
asses are getting bigger so maybe white
dicks will get bigger as well
you know it's an interesting Theory I
like it I had a black guy tell me that
yeah because you got to get past the ass
right to inseminate right I don't know
if I could I don't know if I can get
there yeah I don't even know if I can
get there dude I know and after my dick
would have to wear lifts I'd have to
like be on the shoulder of another dick
in a raincoat it's like Rush Hour on
like a Sunday getting back in the city
like I don't even know if I'm in America
wow okay it can stretch to four to eight
inches
oh all right
interesting I hope you don't get too
aroused I think there's something just
small dick dudes created
only the first two inches are sensitive
yeah dude that baby dick thing is brutal
what's that that like condition that
dudes have that like where they have a
dick that's like a micro like a micro
dick yeah
one ball probably did I know he had one
ball that explains a lot of anger you
don't do that with a big dick you don't
you don't give speeches that anger yeah
true yeah you just don't but that micro
dick is tough when it's like one of
those things on a roulette wheel
bet on black
don't go there
all right last story uh girl discovered
her stepfather is her biggest
only spending over two thousand dollars
how about a few how about
a behind I got to figure out what that
is guys living with her and it broke up
her wedding with her mother huh oh wow
she's she's pretty hot worth it
dang that's uh I mean that's definitely
that's a tough conversation with your
mother like Mom uh your boyfriend's
looking at pictures of me naked on the
internet she's like there are pictures
of you naked on the internet she's like
one thing at a time let's uh yeah right
let me ask you a question though if I am
making a woman and you found out her hot
legal daughter
her hot legal daughter look at that ass
age how do you not my question is
there's not even a chance how do you not
what you can't even order it and look
how do you can't do this too it's too
tempting you can't do it you can't not
you can't do it no you can't do it you
can't do it guys okay
it's just it's too good are you are you
a glutton for punishment are you out of
your mind I'm dating her are you nuts
it's a stepdaughter you know how creepy
that is what's creepy about that well
sneaking to look at your the woman that
you're dating's daughter naked Woody
Allen did this but minus only fans well
his was a little bit this is a little
different he was more of a father figure
to her sure yeah like when did he
married her though
who like
you know they're on their second go Ben
Affleck yeah and young fee and Woody are
still together what's her name Sun fee
excuse me but I have a question is
everyone on [__] only fans yes
because I hear about this all the time
yes and I've never done it I've never
like like clicked on it or anything but
it's amazing there's a there's another
thing internet called porn I've never
I've never even known I never heard of
it I'm not no I know what it is no idea
I've never I'm serious I've never
there's enough porn on the internet that
if I need a look I can look it's fine
dude you could get off tour if you put
pictures of your feet up there
my feet no I don't know you want to see
Carrie fienne's feet it's five bucks a
month now I've seen her in a flip-flop
I'm good yeah I I don't I don't want it
but I have like 20 grand a month or
something she's killing it but you know
uh it's just it's weird but I read this
article and it was like she was
complaining like yeah my stepdad uh like
we narrowed him down to six suspects
like it's a [__] knives out or
something but like we narrowed it down
and I knew I knew and it was him who
went for weeks on the internet and I'm
like I got a great idea for you maybe
stop [__] your boyfriend on the
internet yeah that might be the solution
yeah stop putting it out there if you
don't want creeps to watch I mean yeah
Turning Away good paying customers yeah
I bet you kept the money too yeah she
wasn't like here you go step dad I'd be
upset if he pirated it too but she lives
with him dude yeah but it's a
stepdaughter he he's dating the mom
there's no blood you're gonna look me in
the eye all three and say yes you were
if you were living with and you had this
hot the mom the woman you were dating
his daughter was this hot and she had an
only fans page you're not gonna take a
peek I promise
and Not only would I not do it I would
be so away from it that I would be
disgusting you have to put blinders on
when she comes in the room and knowing
she's only fan maybe look at her
Instagram
she's private oh all right well there
you go yeah now I have to just peek and
you're taking a peek okay here's the
deal you're having breakfast with her in
the morning like you're [__] like
amazing Peters you're opening her
bedroom door you're just peeking in
that's free that's free I didn't only
fans no subscription this ain't 5.99 a
month no pop-up blockers you guys do no
he's not related to either one of these
girls yeah yeah but he's dating them
we're not we're not this is not an
incest thing yeah yeah we're saying like
you're [__] the mom maybe you don't
try to [__] the daughter too this isn't
yeah this isn't the movie of your life
why though why what do you guys [__]
pulp or something like why the pope yeah
because you don't [__] your girlfriend's
daughter
you see you're saying [__] her either we
don't desire I I okay yeah dude it's a
desire and your head is different than
subscribing to pictures of her [__]
another difference if he jerked off to
her in the shower no wait does he watch
her in the shower no but she's not but
she just what jerk stops in the shower
in his mind yeah it's very different
yeah she's advertising it she wants
people to pay no but there's no there's
no evidence would be like she doesn't
want people to write this they say you
know that only fans is is not like you
know admirable at all I'm sorry to say
if you're on it but because like if I
had a stepmom who bought my comedy album
I'd be like thanks
I wouldn't be like you're [__] weird
yeah yeah you know what I mean don't put
my other thing is don't put the [__] out
there if it bothers you who's watching
that's my point and my other point I
agree with that with that my other point
but my other thing is also don't [__]
don't date a woman and then
at least publicly jerk off to the
daughter if you're gonna jerk after the
daughter in your head that no one can
stop you from your imagine nobody knows
that yeah do it unless you want to think
about something unbelievably hot I think
you wait for him to break up with the
lady then do it once you broke it up
this is too weird because you're in the
home yeah he's in the house with him
yeah that's the weird part look he's in
the crib I know you guys are lying no
we're not I'm really not I got I've been
farting all night
dude no we're not we're minions is very
hot let's see what the mom looks like
oh pull up the money if the mom's all
jacked up Mom's on the right right
probably just with the mom to jack off
yeah there's a big difference in giving
a girl like hey would you like two
thousand dollars I want to give it words
like hey I gave you two thousand dollars
jacking off to you there's a big
difference big gift either way though
two thousand dollars is still in your
pocket true yeah I mean I know I sound
like her attorney because I kind of
unless he's a super supportive
stepfather I mean he's great in every
other way
I'm curious what the mom looks like too
though
no no that's her and a different hairdo
oh okay oh is that the family
okay
oh I wish you guys got his arm yeah what
an unromantic reason but like you have
to tell your friends like why'd you call
off the wedding he was jerking off to my
daughter I mean yeah but he was paying
for it but do we know for a fact that he
was jacking off to him but he was just
monitoring her to make sure I think he
would have written a check you think so
yeah I think he was just into supporting
her you just give the money you don't
privately that's what I would have said
well I'm just monitoring it's a cyber
Guardian yeah I'm just I just want to
make sure you're not doing anything too
crazy he's gonna get into college yeah I
would have said to her I would have made
you lie to the to the mother I would be
like look I was gonna tell you I was
just I was doing a secret investigation
yeah I was I was watching her for you
and yes I mean attractive woman but you
don't I don't think you date someone and
then
pay to jerk off to the daughter yes you
can do it for free while she's changing
you don't pay for it unless she's got
only fans I guess so and then you do it
at least make a fake account this guy
was going right out of his bank account
dude that gross thing on the right I
just can't get out of mind yeah is there
a way to get that off I mean it's hard
to be looking at this and then see that
the dick I was confused
his dick looks like after all the guilt
after the jerkin yeah wait can we just
see her on Insta let's see what we're
dealing with here because maybe he could
have just gone for free and looked at
her old bikini pics from dude I'm
buzzing my [__] balls off
I'm not gonna lie I'm definitely I'm
drunk right now I'm not all right like
not really not feeling a thing well I
had three oh yeah three yeah oh that's
different yeah sipping one he's ready
for another one by the way yeah I'll
just do one more top off and then I
gotta really call it too because then
it's gonna get weird is it really not a
see it's not available
oh did you see that [__] that you
know the way there's like these
vigilante going against pedophiles like
they find you like a Target and they're
just like dude you came here to meet
like a a 15 year old boy dude this guy
did you see the one where the guy was in
a parking lot in Denver and he goes call
your wife right now call your wife and
tell her what you did dude and the guy
was married to her for like 40 years and
he just goes and he goes no tell her and
he goes hey babe I mean she goes hey and
you could they were married forever and
he goes God tell him he did he just goes
um I was here
um picking up a 14 year old boy and she
just goes dude she just goes what
and he goes no tell dude it was the
[__] it was actually one of the
hardest things to watch a guy's whole
life and the confusion of his wife know
that everything that they built together
was [__] over it was [__]
I'm here in Denver me meeting with a 14
year old boy understand why and he goes
tell him for sex and he goes for sex and
she's just like what are you kidding me
it was [__] up man that guy makes the
only fans guy look like a prince yes
it's all it's a spectrum yeah I guess so
that guy is on the Spectrum you should
you should not [__] kids yeah that's a
bad decision no [__] kids is bad yeah
it's crazy that there's people out there
that do this I'm just looking at
pictures I feel like I know this girl's
whole life now Matt's just been pulling
up pictures of her non-stop the whole
pocket we can't get one Gander at the at
the mom huh nah she's she'll be on only
fan soon I bet all of this is a crazy
I'm just saying I put myself in that
position like if I'm dating a a mom with
a kid we're grown up I'm in my 60s yeah
we're not we're not there for a second
marriage I'm there to get my rocks off
I'm jerking off to her to everybody yeah
right big enough to the daughter
daughter's friends Jesus
how many drinks you have this is a
darker right how is he the drunk one
right now what the hell I mean I'm not
I'm jerking off to the kids I'm joking
off to the Friends they're jerking off
to everybody these adults dirty a grown
adult parents yeah this is next marriage
Miss I'm not here for you I'm here to
get my rock stop all right
good time what's your daughter's account
I mean it's a fascinating case it's very
a complex case because she's putting the
[__] out there yes and he's looking at
it and she's attractive it is a tough
spot but you know if you live with the
lady you gotta wait till you're broken
up for a very long time man thank you
this is a paper plane Margarita so can
you can you tell us the ingredients
breakdown because I've seen people are
going to want to make that yeah so it's
uh I wish it was my stepdad
Blanco tequila uh about three quarter
ounce uh aperol and a lemon juice and a
little bit of triple sec double get one
we'll go smoke a stick I got a car yeah
me too oh he's driving but I'm in town
for a while
you doing spots tonight no I got I'm
doing more pods later what else you got
me and Bobby Kelly are doing
that one yeah you're gonna be throwing
out the N word It's Gonna Be Wild
Bobby Kelly drunk that's so funny I'm
not here for you
[Applause]
he's gonna kill her up though oh yeah
yeah good time do we finish the news
okay great just checking I might get on
Ollie fans we're done I don't we just
got it well we might as well yeah well
I'm sorry do you guys have any wrecks or
pet peeves anyone like uh we sometimes
we do recommendations on this podcast
and it will be something that Mark's
recommended like we wreck movies
sometimes a book whatever Mark has
recommended taking a walk I I think it's
a great [__] wreck actually oh it's a
great walk you know what I just say I'm
getting into jury duty you guys watching
this is it good it's great it's amazing
what do you mean
sorry was this only fans that's her mom
is that the mom no oh geez was that her
Peters Paul I want to say that word no
that was a different picture that's her
though right yeah let's see the video I
want to see what they what they post
this video is my wreck
first they try a new activewear oh
that's her she's blonde in this one
it was like well into her 20s
yeah yeah
she could be 30. said to me maybe
um how is this content I don't get how
people put certain [__] I don't get what
you're posting you know what is you get
to know them so you're like now I know
this girl who's getting naked I don't
know it's become like just mind-numbing
stuff it's true we're getting Dumber
like I feel Dumber after watching it's
really the lowest right now really
because the fact that some of these Tick
Tock when you see some of these Tick
Tock videos like a 14 million and you
see what it is you're going like 14
million people to watch that [__] my
favorite of the crowd work videos where
the audience is funnier than the comics
yeah you know everyone's just throwing
them up now yeah it's pathetic content
is the bar is getting so low yeah where
are you from Florida yeah
Florida Florida you guys together uh
we're just friends oh he wants to [__]
you yeah dates dates come down yeah
um this is brilliant stuff the thing is
it's uh it like all bubbles it'll burst
because all the a lot of those people
will get some people to come out and see
them and yeah and they'll be a little
disappointed short money and so or we
have another year of this podcast I mean
how long I mean look I'll keep doing it
but I'm just saying like how long does
the is the podcast bubble gonna burst I
can't believe people listen to this and
I I love shopping Mark every week but
I'm Blown Away people listen listen
we'll go away but some the good ones the
funny guys when people respect tune into
you two guys yeah no matter what you do
because you're like incredible Comics
whether you're sitting I was literally
just showing a girl I'm dating uh
mauricia the other day and she was
laughing her ass off I was like this is
one of my I was like let me show you one
of my favorite things and it was Giannis
doing Mauricio which is like I love it
it's one of them I think it's a
brilliant character brilliant and also
that the music video does it I mean it
was like fun I mean that should be a
[__] show you should have you should
do a show as Maurice it's a little dicey
now I don't know dude I think I do
remember that that was the end I think
it was like 2012 I kind of remember but
dicey now it's over it's not nice
anymore yeah it's over now yeah I think
it's over I think I also think it could
be a you didn't do it in a mean way you
did it in a way where you're like this
is like a real human like a yeah it was
a character you did it you did it like a
three-dimensional character yeah and uh
I remember watching you do it live and
laughing my ass off and the crowd ate it
up and they were like it was like a
diverse cool crowd killed you got to be
a real [__] to get mad at that
character yeah that character is nobody
really has no no I was at a wedding and
they were like these old Greeks were
like topanos you know yeah it's comedy
characters just hey Johnny out here
making you laugh yeah get mad at you at
that time but that's why I'm kind of
like man that's like a a sitcom like
that's like I mean you and serge and
yamanika I mean it's like it was great
but you know that I think that error is
kind of over anyway it's just like hey
make videos it's the same but you could
yeah yeah you could make that into
something yeah yeah you could and I
totally could be a car I could be a
sitcom a lot of things could but I just
don't know if anyone's watching sitcoms
anymore no yeah but you can make your
own web show is my point I mean
absolutely I mean there's other [__] you
could do like and I Mark your city's
watching the show I mean people still
watch it it's just you got to jump
through more Hoops to make it but you
could still make you could make
something like that yourself I think
yeah but I think what I think what
Giannis was saying too is is that people
are going to continue to watch content
of people that they know when they go
see are going to deliver continue to be
there and are great at what they do it's
the people that have a podcast or do a
tick tock thing and they blow up real
quick and the crowd gets filled up in a
theater and everyone goes oh my God yeah
yeah and that's happening where people
are going like 15 15 minutes in they're
going everybody's like oh dude I just
kind of like their YouTube channel we
shouldn't have came to this I'm never
coming back well here's that's what it
is now here's what I think I think where
I think Hollywood is being short-sighted
this is my opinion I'm probably right
because it's just the thing about
everything becomes trite when it becomes
saturated right so screens are
everywhere so it's not special anymore
to be on the screen to watch someone on
a screen but going to see someone live
is very special I think that's why
you're seeing such a boom yeah in lives
this is the biggest boom in the history
of humanity there's never been more
Comedians
and there's nothing better than doing it
for an hour and just having a great time
live because those people love for
people it's like it used to be watching
a TV show would be special because
you're watching something on a screen so
like how did you get on there it's still
a few people on a screen great point but
now it's like the the rare thing is to
see someone live and have it be an
amazing show isn't that weird
seeing live entertainment I feel like
100 years ago was a thrill we've come
full circle exactly and then yeah you're
like the moving pictures it's the movies
and now it's you're right it's
completely back to where it was because
it's become it's uh trite it's like uh
you're on a yeah you can watch anything
on a screen you can watch someone
queefing on the screen you can watch
your stepdaughter uh [__] her
boyfriend ice cream and anybody can
upload to Youtube and anybody it's so
commonplace but not everyone could go
and kill and make a lot audience go
crazy for an hour and So eventually that
will be the thing that your TV show will
be your life you'll see like a bunch of
live game shows yeah are you garbage
stand-ups like a live great show but
then this special event by your logic
will live get boring and then go back to
something else absolutely okay but no I
don't think a live performance that's
good will never get boring well it'll
become old it'll become like you know
everything it does nothing goes forever
it'll you know like Broadway was hot for
a while everything yeah like radio it
changes things I hope I hope that like
some production companies get it
together though because like I love
movies I love I love movies too me too I
really do like I love like good movies
and movies that take risks and it's
harder I think it's harder to make a
movie that's risky like they'll always
be there I just feel it but I feel like
so many of the movies that are like
getting made now are like superhero
movies and like yeah horror movies
enough horror but yeah but at least
horror can they're coming at it with an
original way sometimes I feel like this
superhero [__] is just
nothing is more sad than when you see
the behind the scenes of those Marvel
movies and it's just all those huge
A-list actors standing in front of green
screens they're all just standing in
like the same room yeah like looking up
it's it's [__] off and some of them
are fun but they've just made so much
yeah you want you long for the days of
like like Mark and I romanticize like
the late 60s 70s period of film where
we're like obsessed with give me like a
cuckoo's nest yeah [__] yeah but where
you're like this is a [__] movie yeah
I feel where you feel something and I
don't know it's that's what's less of
those air was enjoy air I don't know if
you saw eight I can't wait to see it my
brother my little brother my older
brother just texted me he said it's
incredible it's really good you gotta
watch it and the fact that it's true you
know some movies you're watching like
this would never happen but it's true so
you're like you're you're locked in
because you're like this really happened
that makes it more fun I think people
still watch stuff when it's amazing yeah
well that but I think but that goes to
questions but that goes to what we're
saying about Comics like you know you've
been doing com I've been doing comedy to
over 20 years you've been doing comedy
over 20 how many years 16 how many years
around that yeah yeah so it's like once
when somebody is just doing spots for
years yeah it has been into those rooms
Giannis was saying where you're in
somebody's living room but you're also
at the cellar you're also done theaters
you also done when you do that for a
long time that's going to just be a
better show than somebody that's not so
that was going to get phased out for
sure that's just going to get phased
it's so fun because I see these young
Comics running around like you do the
roads you have some host open for you
and he's like 22. he's green and he's
like this guy's got eight million views
he's got 40 000 followers and you're
like but they are they're all bad and
they can't see the the forest from the
trees or like he's got 100 million
followers what the hell but I'm like
he's got no act right it comes back to
the ACT you gotta be able to kill you
gotta be good Focus so much on building
the brand yeah you're neglecting yes you
know and and that's not I'm not calling
this an art settle down I'm not like
trying to sound pretentious with this
[__] I know we're clowns as we said
before traveling calm down but like you
know uh there's you neglect this and you
focus on the other aspects of it and
look it's two different in businesses
that's right it's fun in the moment it's
fun and it's great to build this and and
it makes it easier when people come out
to see you but man you really gotta Mark
and I talked this about this to death is
like the more [__] you do to promote
this to sell tickets on the road the
more you're taken away from what we did
every day like Mark and I as open mikers
meet in a coffee shop and bouncing bits
and that's that was really the premise
that was the podcast that was like right
right we used to like get [__] coffee
and just be like is this funny no is it
funny you know I mean that's we we
labored over jokes and I and I miss that
sometimes I mean we there's still time
but it but I feel like we're losing
times no phone calls used to be hey man
I wrote this joke about this and what do
you think yeah and now it's going like
hey man if I do this you think I could
get like a thousand more followers it is
[__] up let's go viral has this been
done yeah it's not the same but that
being said this is good what we're doing
right here I'm enjoying this and I know
this is like I think hopefully people
enjoy this and and there's still ways to
be creative sure but uh I but I want to
make shows I want to do other stuff it's
not just like uh it there's a lot you
can do here and I want to be creative in
other ways you know yeah yeah oh
absolutely yeah but it's it's I think
it's out there it's possible yeah
sometimes you just do it yourself you
just oh yourself that's what you got to
do now maybe just take your money and
just make something I think that's what
I gotta yeah that's like we were saying
with the uh with the industry they take
eight million years to get a meeting
going and we have notes and the notes
take two weeks and you gotta apply the
notes that takes another two weeks just
[__] make it yeah well that's why
they couldn't compete because they were
doing that and people were just putting
stuff out on the internet and then when
the quality evened out with the
technology coming down in price it was
just over right because they they rely
on so many so much [__] to justify
so many people's jobs that that's why
they stretch it out
God calls you then this guy's then you
know exactly it's like when Elon came
and slashed and yeah yeah they still ran
you're like what's going on that but you
need that I don't you need people who
have fake jobs because what are they
going to do now well no one's working
now yeah I mean I'm scared you guys
aren't scared about this a little not
for us we're going to be fine oh first
of all I don't know if we're gonna be
fine we'll be okay comedy will always
comedy's like the bar business people go
there when they're feeling sad and since
life is [__] will always be in business
there's only two things that go up in
crisis it's alcohol and entertainment by
the way it's like the classic Sopranos
thing the two things that are Recession
Proof the mafia and most forms of
entertainment yeah I would think of
Silvio saying that to Tony but uh I
don't know if I believe it with comedy
because I I you know you never know what
happens I mean with covid we lost so
much and like thank God it came back but
like you never man we survived yeah but
what do you think what do you think what
do you think would happen in comedy
where people robots they can't robots
don't do context yeah and they don't
have the emotional we'll see I I don't
know I hey man I I don't want to be a
pessimist here but who the [__] knows
how smart this technology gets that's
how about they just stop the robots now
how about just it just stops dude that's
the weird thing well technology will it
never stops it always wins the horse and
Buggies out you know but the weird thing
is the Google head of Google was like
this is bad we gotta shut this down and
you're like you're the [__] are you made
the goddamn yeah and you kept the money
yeah how about you give up your house
yeah exactly the scary thing is they're
all saying this is bad no and but didn't
the one robot go like to take over the
human race didn't it say that they asked
like what's your goal and one of them
was like to take over the human race and
they were like all right off button yeah
they can animate it can draw it can you
can you can do legal work it can dig
songs what is it Mateo Lane yeah it's
really as talented as him it's
Vaudeville it can they can put they can
put like Christian Walker in Fast and
Furious movies for the rest of uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
no immigration
There's a comic I'm not gonna say who
but he went on stage with the seller
last night he was like I'm gonna read an
AI joke and I'm going to read a joke
that I did but I won't tell you which
one is which and he read the he read the
first one and I was like I was cute
whatever kind of something then he read
the second one and it killed and he was
like thank God I wrote the second one
and you're like all right we're still
okay well it's like Giannis said the AI
can't get the emotion of the story or
the jokes like when you attack you know
when you bomb a joke and you go well
that joke bombed and that gets a laugh
AI won't be able to do that yeah AI will
be able to they won't be able to feel
that like oh [__] I'm vomiting awareness
and yeah to be able to yeah and they
won't be like look at her tits and uh
that guy won't shut the [__] up you know
and the room's weird you know you make
fun there's a chandelier in here I'm
talking about my dick hey guys listen to
this podcast they're like look at her
tits
killer punch line I'm bombing stuff to
recognize will AI be able to scan tits I
think of the movie ex machina all the
time it's such an incredible movie but I
I like oh my God that's like a
terrifying glampson of like who knows
maybe right well the scary thing is that
yeah he con contacts that's what makes
us human is context yes that's where the
soul lies and context that yeah I I
can't uh discern the difference and you
know that's I it's interesting that we
don't never think about the fact that
we've been conditioned by AI like we're
being raised like these Generations are
being raised by algorithms oh yeah and
then when you see people acting like
because people act like hey I know they
hear a word and they're like I'm
offended you're like he didn't hear the
context you're a robot that's
interesting why are you acting like this
I was raised by one I do so many
interviews with people like are you
worried about censorship and comedy I
say not like I'm not worried about
people being offended right I could give
a [__] about that I'm worried about
algorithms hearing certain words like
the word Nazi and I can be condemning
Nazis in a joke but they hear the word
Nazi so they just bury the joke right
and I'm like well that's Nuance right
there yeah you're ignoring Nuance so I
worry about that in terms of like like
you know burying jokes I don't worry
about people being like that joke is
offensive [__] them who can give a [__]
about them they weren't gonna they
weren't gonna get the joke anyway right
if they tuned out you don't feel it
really live you don't really feel
anything especially on the road yeah on
the road you don't feel it but yeah I
mean people because there are people act
like they know what to expect yeah
they're real people live the context is
live they're people they get it they see
your expression they know the context of
we've gathered into this Comedy Club to
hear inappropriate things said ingest
they get sarcasm you get irony but you
know not not AI what do you think and
your fans know you so you don't know
your fans are coming for you that's not
ever going to be they're huge they know
what to expect yeah but what do you
think it is about a joke that really
gets under people's skin whereas like an
action movie or a rape scene or uh a
murder it's the truth is that what it is
suicide
I think it's I think it's that in the
movie they've accepted that these are
characters and on stage they think this
is you I think that's what it is think
the political I think the political
divide and everything that the media
does and separates people when you say
something up there they automatically I
think they put you in that category
whichever aisle they think you're on and
I think that they're judging you on that
too well I think I think the algorithm
has done that too has increasingly made
everyone extreme I think the algorithm
where people are like literally weren't
meant to see the joke well like like the
people who meant to see the joke but
then the random people just kind of open
the door and be like I don't like that
joke you weren't meant to say it yeah
they're peeking it I mean now everyone
sees the joke yeah yeah well the people
who get angry at it that's content for
them well like we were talking about
create their contacts when we were
talking before we were talking before
about the drag queens and I said on on
this podcast I go why are they I just
want to know why they're in a school
with an eight-year-old yeah and now
somebody could listen to that and go oh
versus a [__] but no you don't know
my uh you know but that that happens
everywhere you don't know how I really
feel about everything yes I'm just
saying that type of thing I could see it
being confusing and don't understand why
it's there but now somebody listened to
this going [__] him he's
they're not famous enough if you get
famous enough they'll find some because
it's content for that person yes I
remember hearing Colin Quincy guys if
they if they want to cancel you all they
need is Wi-Fi yeah they all they'll
fight a reason yeah they'll find
something they'll take a clip here
they'll they'll figure it out that's why
it's good not to get famous you don't
want to get too famous yeah you'll just
fly too close to the sun right you want
it to stay right but can we ever get to
a point where we're getting where we're
calling out these people who use our
livelihood as content well I think isn't
that evil yeah well I'm just sick of it
I think it's like it's a boy I think it
still works
we're using his livelihood for our
comedy there's what he's already done
done
what do you mean like he already killed
a lady yeah
the lady's dead
it's in the news by the way there was a
story that he was like a dick to a
server yeah and you're just and you're
just like you murdered someone you can't
be nice for like a year and a half
you can't give us like a year and a half
of being nice like Alec Baldwin shot a
woman in the face right or whatever he
shot her yeah she was a mother and like
a wife and then like I literally
immediately he's like he's like you're
you're nothing to a server you're like
[__] you you gotta be nice for a year
and a half at least yeah that should be
that should be a sentence like you got
off and the judge should be like you
can't ever be rude to a waitress a
waiter well Gillis admittedly said he's
like after I got nicer I got way nicer I
got canceled yeah so that's kind of nice
he got also a lot more famous as well so
that helped but you know what Shane got
famous because he he didn't get bitter I
mean that was one of the beautiful
things about Shane I think is that like
yeah he could have that could have
happened to him and he could become a
huge dick but I think what happened was
he was like I'm just gonna go all in on
on my stuff yep funny and being funny
and he was he was like nice in his
comedy I thought I think there was like
like in like in a way yeah I talked to
him about it and he's I was like dude
look what you did you out there doing
your thing now he goes oh thanks man it
was about being silly and funny and he
didn't get crazy there was no there was
no malice and bitterness because you get
guys that go far the other way they're
[__] doing podcasts I remember I
talked to him after it happened I said I
really hope you don't ever go that way
and he goes I won I said good he's too
smart yeah but I I'm funny he's talented
so funny guys some guys some some guys
you know they just go [__] you you did
this to me well now I'm gonna go in the
woods and do a podcast by a [__]
bonfire yeah you know and they start and
they go they put their chips in the
other way real big yeah right I got bad
news there's already a podcast called
the bonfire so you're in big trouble but
here's the thing you can't ignore the
fact that those things do backfire and
make people more famous
canceling yeah I mean it does put your
name it depends on if you're huge it
takes you down but
it could possibly inflate you know your
ticket sales but if it's over something
behavioral you you're finished
kind of finished
I mean two sold out shows at the Beacon
does he yes
really still doing a solo
I didn't know that yeah yeah wow I mean
his fans don't care now listen and it
sounds like he sold out four shows at a
middle school too which I thought was
kind of weird but he's what you call
Black Friday Shopper he shows up a
little too early to the store
you're like hey guy it's not open yet
interesting whoa so but you know it's
just still people well the Bud Light
lady whatever Dylan Mulvaney yeah huge
very nice unicorn lady oh well done is
it still Dylan diliana no you never know
I think oh either yeah
okay but yeah huge yeah I mean but
Delia's yeah you can't get worse than
that and he it's still sold out feeders
two of them
you know and then all the other ones I
think his whole [__] schedules sold
out
so wow yeah the problem with this stuff
is I think they go too far you know it's
like some people deserve some people
deserve to have consequence culture take
them down but by the Rolling Stone
article on them and it was pretty uh it
was rough it was pretty troubling rough
yeah yeah so it's a troubling but I
think when you try to cancel everybody
you kind of you numb people too yes you
enjoy the crib wolf and so that's when
you do anything too much we do it with
racist Nazi
and Louie and Aziz got swept in with
that [__] Weinstein and Cosby thing
and they shouldn't have worse
I remember if CNN did a thing where it
was like people who have been canceled
this year and it was Cosby Weinstein and
Shane Gillis this is like an s.a.t
question which one doesn't belong right
that's hard this is so [__] on that's
so ridiculous horrible when it's a one
size fits-all condemnation system yes
it's like this is ludicrous this is
completely crazy and I want to talk at a
turn here but I will be honest like I'm
speaking as a dad with a daughter but
I'll be honest like
asking a woman if you can take your dick
out is kind of the nicest way to take it
[Music]
can I do you mind if I take my dick
that's the funniest question as a
daughter who as a father who one day
have a daughter will grow up I can only
hope that a guy would say do you mind if
I take my dick out right it's a very
polite thing to do because usually I've
never I've usually just taken out yeah
right yeah yeah that's true that was my
old I kind of liked one that I kind of
liked when the woman was like do you
mind taking a dick out yeah that's kind
of hot that's a better that was a better
way but I just sign up for their
daughter's only fans
but yeah yeah it's all topsy-turvy and
it's tough and it's weird what's
controversial like just that statement
is controversial yeah and you're like
but isn't that kind of normal talk I
don't know to be funny so I don't know
what he did I mean I wasn't in the room
right I don't know he's I just he's a
great comment well you know what I
talked to all I talked to like
Old-Timers who said that was the way
like I talked to like I talked to dudes
that were like back in like the day you
would be on a date and you would like if
you pulled it out it was like the
[__] I don't know about that no in
the restaurant no no no no no no no no
no no I'm saying what you said yeah like
yeah back in the day it was like hey
what are we doing with this oh yeah but
I I gotta be honest with you and I'm
serious I'm not I could not for me I was
always had to be like the she had to be
the aggressor I was always afraid I was
like that too but you still can't deny
the fact that like nobody asked I still
didn't ask it was just like I took it
out we were like she got undressed I
took it out yeah but I think I think
there's much difference she's getting
undressed you take your dick out but
there's a read in the room
right there you know hey you gotta read
the room you gotta know the feelings
right to do that and I've never taking
out with a woman that's a hundred
percent right yeah you're right but I
also never politely asked which is very
nice yeah for me they asked me to take
it out and then I do and then they're
mad yeah yeah that that's it Jesus you
have to keep it all night nothing was
worse than diseases yeah but I tell you
the only reason he got in trouble was he
was wearing a [__] me too that's what
got him don't you gotta be quiet he was
wearing the me too pins at the Oscars
and [__] it's like look if you like the
fish it was the very beginning too it
was also the very beginning of it it was
a very but it [__] him up like he said
no I remember ways to kill himself and
all that it's brutal he lost that show
that show was great right no it came
back but he got kicked off the show oh
yeah yeah he was removed from the show
because he fished with the girl and
that's what kills me is it's all about
now it's about compassion and being not
like if you call a gay guy a homo you'll
get crucified but like how is that what
they did a disease not inconsiderate and
immoral and mean yeah that's a different
kind of mean that's I think there's I
think nuance and there's layers of this
[__] and I think he was kind of made an
example of I think I think it's this but
that's not nice I mean it's cool
I'm not not at all saying it's okay I
think it was like the beginning of a lot
of Penta Banger and and none of this has
been dealt with and I mean I think Aziz
was dealt with before Harvey Weinstein
which I'm like I mean it might be
[__] up the timeline here but like
maybe we deal with The Predator first
yeah no Aziz was the worst one because
nobody read that article and thought he
was wrong not one person read that
article and was like well it wasn't on a
real order it was on babe died I know
but it was just got him canceled from
the show which is great it still messed
up his career it still was bad his
parents had to know what he likes to do
it's like that girl did a messed up
thing that's the wrong thing she did I
think I think this works both ways
though like right I completely agree
with you the Aziz thing was insanely
[__] up but then like
rape laws are insanely [__] up the
fact that like try getting an order of
protection in certain States when a dude
has actually tried Prosecuting a dude
who's actually raped you it's insanely
hard so I I agree with you but I think I
think it works both ways I mean you know
I didn't think this is going to get this
heavy but we're two and a half hours
into a podcast
nowhere to go but I kind of like it I
think I think it works both ways as well
and I think as I agree with you as he's
got [__] but like it is insanely hard
you know
Prosecuting rape Yes Yes No One Believes
you even the cops are like what were you
wearing were you yeah there's a lot of
that especially he was insane the 90s
were insane it's so very bad there's
definitely an over correction but as
long as we can realize it's an over
correction that's what we got to do now
but we should be the guy who gets
correct I think all I'm saying isn't
this gonna sound preachy but like get
just as angry as the dudes who are maybe
still touring and selling out two shows
at the Beacon I'm very angry at that you
know
you know who is going to that show
ironically who ladies
well I'm opening not a neat and clean
world but yeah it's the same thing it's
like it's like when women yell at us
about the WNBA it's like ladies we're
not watching either way and guess what
and either I watch more wnb than you do
[__] exactly I love Brianna Stewart
Liberty or stack this year let's [__]
go I mean that's where I draw the line
that's where I draw the line but let's
let's plug some dates where you guys
going to be coming up when does this
come when is this let's put
June 11th so yeah Paul we're gonna oh
June 11th oh June 11th I'm gonna be at
uh I'll be at Side Splitters
I'm gonna be at yeah I'll be at Side
Splitters June 15th to the 17th check me
out then uh the next two in June I'm
gonna be uh Houston Improv and Dallas
improv All Dates at paulversy.com is
that three podcasts can I plug those
plug them I got uh the version the
version effect podcast which is now in
studio doing great I got bone to pick
podcast with Bobby Kelly anything better
with Bill Burr and nocturnal admissions
is on Netflix right now you guys could
check that out man thank you guys so
much for having support both these guys
great Comics great dudes go see them on
the road watch all their stuff yeah
nobody's listening it's probably still
by now but just go to my website they
are they're definitely got loads of
dates uh uh but the next one I'll be at
is the Wilbur in Boston please
sell the rest of those tickets one of
the best theaters in the country easily
easily and then uh you know the
Paramount in Long Island August 17th and
then a bunch of other dates I saw Wise
Guys there too which is one of my
favorites yeah I love white blue room's
great yeah that's a great Calgary's
killer don't sleep on couch Wise Guys
Utah might be one of my favorites ever
great so you got there Red Bank the
vocal these are great rooms
so Sony home New York just go to
giannisepapiscomedy.com in my podcast
the honest Pappas hour hell yeah where
you at Sammy uh you know Denver Santa Fe
San Antonio Houston we just added a
bunch of [__] we got uh Montreal coming
Providence Northampton Massachusetts
Burlington Vermont oh no not Syracuse we
didn't do that we're doing Albany
instead I I like my life decided to make
that change Toronto uh all over Phoenix
we just added uh you know a lot of
California dates Cincinnati Columbus
Indianapolis so much good stuff coming
up by Bodega cat whiskey at Bodega
catwhiskey.com Norman what's going on
dude I'll be in Australia for a little
more time come out and say hello we're
selling like hotcakes out there and then
I'm coming back to do an American tour
Milwaukee Des Moines Los Angeles New
Orleans Alabama Mississippi Louisville
San Diego Cincinnati Springfield
Chesterfield Missouri Hershey PA DC
Oklahoma Dallas Portland Maine
Providence you name it get some Bodega
cat get some shirts we got a Rick and
Morty over there I love this one this
one made me happy I just saw this before
the show check out our specials July
25th for Netflix uh we got a mom love
Mom yeah check out my shoes online mom
love thank you uh nocturnal nocturnal
admissions Netflix hell yeah these are
two Real Deal Comics support them check
them out on the road watch their [__]
thank you guys we don't have people on
the show we don't respect the time
appreciate it so yeah uh I mean classic
episode this is like what three hours
how long was it three no 220 all right
all right I felt like three what's the
record what are you gonna be Danny beard
you
I'm still at uh say less in Midtown and
good room and green point so come out
I'll make you a drink hey you heard it
here first folks we'll see you in hell
and support Aziz we'll see at the Beacon
[Music]
much
dangerous
[Music]
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
true